rappel la déclaration du gouvernement
sur la place de la stratégie vaccinale
dans le dispositif de lutte contre
l'épidémie de kevin 19 suivi d'un débat
en application de l'article 50-1 de la
constitution la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre
[Applaudissements]
à
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
voici un an qui est apparue en chine
le coronavirus responsables de la crise
sanitaire la plus grave que notre pays
et tu affrontes et depuis plus d'un
siècle
la deuxième vague qui frappe l'europe
entière depuis le début d'automne est
d'une violence redoutable ce virus ne
perd pas en intensité bien au contraire
il continue à progresser à faire des
victimes à gagner de nouvelles
géographies selon des règles qui
continuent à échapper à la pleine
compréhension des scientifiques
nous invitons toutes et tous à
l'humilité la pandémie se traduit aussi
en france comme ailleurs par la mise en
place de restrictions importantes qui
met à rude épreuve
nos concitoyens déjà éprouvés par plus
de 10 mois d'efforts
la situation sanitaire reste aujourd'hui
préoccupante
comme vous le savez nous avons atteint
depuis une dizaine de jours un plateau
ancré à un niveau ne nous permettant pas
de garantir une pleine maîtrise de la
circulation virale et ce d'autant que
nous approchons des fêtes de fin d'année
qui est une période à risque
aujourd'hui encore nous comptons une
personne hospitalisée toutes les minutes
et une personne admise d'urgence en
réanimation toutes les sept minutes
l'arrivée du vaccin et le lancement
maintenant imminent de la campagne
vaccinale dans notre pays constitue
cependant un motif d'espoir car nous
serons alors dotée de larmes que nous
attendions pour à terme mettre cette
crise derrière
les questions sur les vaccins sont chez
nos concitoyens nombreuses et c'est
pourquoi j'ai présenté avec les
ministres compétents le 2 décembre
dernier les grandes lignes de la
stratégie vaccinale de la france
cependant l'importance de l'étape que va
représenter dans la lutte contre la
pandémie l'arrivée des vaccins
justifient pleinement selon moi que la
représentation nationale puisse en
connaître et un débattre en amont un
amant de son déploiement
c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité avec le
ministre des solidarités de la santé
olivier veyrat dans le cadre fixé par
l'article 50-1 de notre constitution
précisé devant vous les fondements de
notre stratégie vaccinale ses modalités
de mise en oeuvre mais aussi la façon
dont nous l'intégrons à notre dispositif
global de lutte contre le viol
fondamentalement attaché au rôle du
parlement je crois aux vertus de la
délibération collective
au delà de la séance de ce jour
j'ai souhaité un cadre de dialogue
pérenne avec vous sur la crise sanitaire
avec la mise en place d'un comité
permanent que j'ai installé le 7
décembre dernier et qui comprend le
président de chacune des assemblées et
les présidents de l'ensemble des groupes
parlementaires
alors que le niveau d'immunité
collective reste insuffisant et que la
science n'a pas encore mis au point des
traitements antiviraux pleinement
efficace le vaccin peut être la solution
qui permettra de protéger durablement
nos concitoyens face au virus les
objectifs que nous assignons à la
campagne vaccinale sont claires
en ciblant d'abord les publics les plus
vulnérables
nous cherchons à réduire la mortalité
attribuable à la co vite 19 et à
prévenir les hospitalisations et en
particulier les admission en soins
intensifs et en réanimation
nous espérons ainsi préserver notre
système de santé dans la durée et donc
permettre à notre pays de retrouver un
fonctionnement normal
avec la reprise progressive de
l'ensemble de son activité
si l'arrivée du vaccin est porteuse
d'espérance elle nous place
collectivement et le gouvernement au
premier chef
face à un défi majeur les
responsabilités de l'état sont grandes
et c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite vous dire en toute transparence
comment nous entendons les assumer nous
préparons cette échéance depuis de longs
mois et plusieurs étapes majeures ont
été franchies la première a été la
sécurisation de nos approvisionnements
vaccin dès le printemps dernier vous le
savez mesdames et messieurs les députés
la france a pris l'initiative pour que
soit constitué une task force européenne
visant à acquérir les vaccins ensemble
de façon à peser plus fort dans les
négociations et inviter une compétition
entre pays européens pour être le
premier servi
concrètement cette task force nous a
permis d'obtenir des prix très
attractifs et surtout identique
identique pour tous les pays européens
des garanties sur la transparence des
données et surtout d'assurer que tous
les vaccins soient livrés à chaque pays
européen
au même moment grâce à cela la france à
précommander près de 200 millions de
doses permettant de vacciner
100 millions de personnes puisque vous
le savez pour la plupart des vaccins
deux injections seront nécessaires nous
serons livrés au fur et à mesure que les
vaccins obtiendront leur autorisation de
mise sur le marché
à ce stade nous comptons bien entendu
sur les vaccins des plus avancés le
vaccin freizer et le vaccin moderna
d'autres se situe en phase iii des
essais cliniques comme astrazeneca aux
gens c'est et pourrait donc être
disponible dans les mois qui viennent
même s'il faut rester à ce stade prudent
sur des échéances précises
compte tenu des incertitudes liées aux
essais en cours alors que la demande
internationale est actuellement très
forte pour les premiers vaccins phase
d'autorisation et les chaînes de
production mises sous tension
nous savons que nous entrons dans une
période cruciale et nous sommes
particulièrement vigilants pour garantir
la livraison des doses commandées dans
les délais prévus
la deuxième étape c'est la définition de
notre stratégie vaccinale avec
l'identification des publics à vacciner
en priorité sur ce point notre ligne
directrice est clair ce sera celle fixée
par une autorité médicale indépendante
la haute autorité de santé
dans son avis rendu public le 30
novembre dernier celle ci nous
recommande de donner la priorité aux
personnes à un risque de formes graves à
raison de leur âge et de leurs facteurs
de comorbidité
c'est ce qui fonde le fait que notre
campagne débutera conformément à cet
avis par les personnes les plus âgées
accueillies dans les établissements
comme les ehpad
cette première phase concerne environ un
million de personnes et cette campagne
mesdames et messieurs les députés va
débuter dans les tout prochains jours
dès que nous aurons eu la décision
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché de
l' agence européenne du médicament qui
est attendu qui est attendu le 21
décembre prochain
dans la foulée la haute autorité de
santé donnera son avis concernant les
conditions d'utilisation du vaccin
c'est à partir de là que nous pourront
officiellement lancer notre campagne
vaccinale
si toutes les conditions sont réunies
les premières vaccinations pourraient
donc être réalisés dès la dernière
semaine du mois de décembre avant de
monter en puissance à partir de début
janvier
cette première phase s'échelonnera sur
une période de six à huit semaines pour
tenir compte notamment du délai de 21
jours entre la première vaccination et
le rappelle dans un deuxième temps
toujours sur la base de l'avis de la
haute autorité de santé
nous élargirons les populations
vaccinées au fur et à mesure des
approvisionnements en commençant par les
près de 14 millions de personnes
présentant un facteur de risque lié à
leur âge ou une pathologie chronique
ainsi que par certains professionnels de
santé
pour cette deuxième phase de la campagne
vaccinale qui concernera principalement
les personnes vivant à leur domicile
nous mettrons en place un autre parcours
vaccinale et mobiliseront l'ensemble de
nos professionnels de santé nous nous
appuierons notamment sur les relations
déjà établies entre les médecins
traitants et leurs patients pour
diffuser toute l'information vérifiée
les contre-indications recueillir le
consentement
chacun devra pouvoir se faire vacciner
par un professionnel de chanter à côté
de chez lui qu'il connaît et en qui il a
confiance
le dispositif sera étroitement concertés
avec toutes les parties prenantes
sous la responsabilité du ministre des
solidarités et de la santé
ce n'est que dans un troisième temps à
la fin du printemps que nous ouvrirons
la vaccination à l'ensemble de la
population
mesdames et messieurs les députés les
bases de cette stratégie étant posé il
convient désormais de la mettra nos
oliviers véran vous exposera dans un
instant les modalités de sa déclinaison
opérationnelle
le président de la république a souhaité
qu'elle repose sur deux grands principes
premièrement la confiance il nous faut
d'abord rappeler que si un vaccin est
autorisée ce n'est qu'au terme d'une
procédure rigoureuse d'essai et
d'évaluation à la fois européenne et
nationale
c'est aussi au plus près de nos
concitoyens que la confiance se gagnera
dans le cadre du lien de proximité qui
les unit à nos professionnels de santé
et notamment j ai fait référence au
médecin traitant
c'est pour rétablir cette confiance
qu'une consultation médicale sera
proposée en amont de l'acte de
vaccination et que celui ci devra
toujours être organisée sous une
supervision médicale
aucune vaccination y compris bien
entendu dans les établissements n'aura
lieu
sans que le consentement éclairé et pu
être exprimés j'attends par ailleurs un
avis du comité consultatif national
d'éthique annoncée pour demain qui nous
éclairera sur les questions qui se
posent dans le cadre de cette campagne
vaccinale
deuxième principe majeur la transparence
je m'engage à ce que durant toute la
campagne de vaccination les différentes
parties prenantes soient associés aux
décisions que nous prendrons
c'est notamment la raison pour laquelle
j'ai souhaité placer auprès du ministre
des solidarités de la santé un conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
présidée par le professeur alain fischer
dans les mines en parcours d'immunologie
sts nous sera particulièrement précieux
le conseil sera sur sa proposition
composé d'experts aux compétences et à
l'expérience reconnue pour répondre aux
questions scientifiques éthique
organisationnel sociétal qui se poseront
tout au long de la campagne vaccinale ce
conseil contribuera à la diffusion large
des connaissances actuelles sur les
vaccins en général mais surtout sur ceux
qui nous aideront à lutter contre la
corvette 19
j'ai également saisi le conseil
économique social et environnemental
pour qu'il mette en place un dispositif
de participation citoyenne chargé
d'émettre des observations et de
formuler des recommandations sur la
politique vaccinale
le cee me remettra vendredi ses
propositions relatives à la mise en
place et à l'animation de ce collectif
ce citoyen par ailleurs
le ministre des solidarités et de la
santé a installé trois instance
permanente rassemblant des représentants
des collectivités territoriales des
professionnels de santé et des
scientifiques qui seront informés en
continu des décisions et pourront
intervenir autant qu'ils le souhaitent
pour alerter ou faire des préconisations
mesdames et messieurs les députés
l'arrivée du vaccin marquera un tournant
ici comme ailleurs dans la lutte contre
la copie
mais soyons clairs compte tenu du
processus progressif que je vous ai
présenté le début de la campagne
vaccinale ne va pas marquer la fin de
l'épidémie
tant que nous n'aurons pas atteint un
niveau d'immunité collective suffisant
il continuera d'être indispensable de
mobiliser des autres axes de notre
politique avec d'une part
l'identification et l'isolément rapide
des personnes infectées par le virus
la stratégie tester alerte est protégé
et d'autre part les différentes mesures
préventives
qu'avons nous en effet collectivement
appris de la gestion de cette crise
depuis plus de 10 mois
dis-moi long et éprouvant en france
comme partout dans le monde que sa
maîtrise suppose d'agir parfois
simultanément sur plusieurs leviers et
qu'aucun ne saurait se suffire à
lui-même le premier levier de notre
politique c'est la stratégie tester
alerte et protégés l'objectif que je
vous soumets et que je vous invite à
partager est clairement d'amplifier
cette stratégie dans chacune de ces
dimensions
non que notre bilan à la matière soit
insuffisant puisque nous faisons partie
je vous le rappelle depuis plusieurs
mois des trois pays européens qui
testent le plus mais nous devons faire
mieux encore pour deux raisons
essentielles
l'une est épidémiologique le dépistage
en grand nombre doit nous permettre de
mieux comprendre l'épidémie les
modalités de circulation du virus les
lieux de contamination
tel est d'ailleurs l'un des objectifs
des quatre expérimentation de masse
testing engagée cette semaine dans
ardennes métropole et dans la communauté
urbaine du havre et à partir du 11
janvier à roubaix et à saint-etienne
ces campagnes nous les encourageons et
d'autres se déroule en france dans le
cadre de conventions signées avec les
agences régionales de santé
le retour d'expérience de liverpool et
de la slovaquie démontre toutefois que
nous ne saurions faire de cet outil
l'alpha et l'oméga de notre politique de
dépistage
la seconde raison est évidemment
curative et relèvent une approche
individualisée en la matière notre
objectif est clair remonter briser les
chaînes de contamination le plus
rapidement possible mais aussi garantir
l'effectivité de l' isolement nous
disposons déjà aujourd'hui d'une
capacité de dépistage pouvant monter
jusqu'à 3 millions de tests par semaine
nous devons continuer à l'amplifier un
améliorant encore les délais notamment
grâce à la mise en place depuis
aujourd'hui d'un système de bonus malus
pour les laboratoires qui doit nous
permettre de nous approcher de 100% de
résultats rendus en 24 heures la semaine
dernière
ce sont les derniers chiffres dont je
dispose 78% des résultats des analyses
ont été rendus dans les 24 heures nous
accélérons aussi le déploiement des
tests antigénique plus de 22 mille
professionnels de santé libéraux dans
huit mille pharmaciens d'officine
réalise actuellement plus de 300 mille
tests antigénique par semaine nous avons
de surcroît ouvert depuis le 4 décembre
la possibilité de réaliser ces tests aux
sages femmes aux masseurs
kinésithérapeutes et aux chirurgiens
dentistes
nous avons également travaillé avec tous
les partenaires afin que les entreprises
et les collectivités territoriales qui
le souhaitent puissent déployer avec la
pluie des autorités préfectorales g
sanitaire des opérations de dépistage
collectif par test antigénique pour
remonter rapidement les chaînes de
contamination mieux identifier les lieux
de contamination et prend de vitesse
l'épidémie nous allons encore renforcer
les moyens alloués au traçage des cas en
autorisant le recrutement supplémentaire
de 4000 e tp à l'assurance maladie
nous enrichissons aussi les
fonctionnalités de l'application tous
antico vide qui a déjà été téléchargée
par plus de 11 millions de personnes
avec notamment une utilisation dans les
lieux considéré comme un risque de
transmission reste enfin mesdames et
messieurs les députés le volet de l'
isolement qui est crucial car de notre
capacité à assurer l'effectivité des
ports notre aptitude à freiner la
progression de l'épidémie
quelques pays on vous le savez fait le
choix d'instaurer un isolement
obligatoires dont le non-respect est
passible de sanctions parfois lourdes
tel n'est pas le cas en france
houle isolement des personnes testées
positives et de leurs cas contact
s'effectue sur la base du volontariat
j'ai consulté sur le président dans le
cadre du comité permanent que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure
les présidents de vos groupes pour
recueillir leur avis sur ce sujet très
majoritairement ils ont considéré qu'il
était préférable d'en pour des motifs
d'acceptabilité que d'efficacité d'axer
nos efforts sur le renforcement de
l'accompagnement humain des personnes
malades et donc d'écarter tout
dispositif coercitif mais je
souhaiterais que vous puissiez à nouveau
vous prononcer sur ce sujet dans le
cadre du présent débat public en toute
hypothèse à partir du mois de janvier
chaque personne positive se verra
proposer une visite à domicile par une
équipe soignante et un accompagnement
social s'est investi ce pas important
qui mobilisera plus de 1500 infirmiers
libéraux et 3000 accompagnateurs sociaux
par jour les collectivités territoriales
avec lesquels nous sommes en relation
permanente seront entièrement partie
prenante au déploiement de cette
nouvelle approche
vous avez également par le vote d'un
amendement au projet de loi de finances
pour 2021 permis la levée du délai de
carence pour toutes les personnes devant
s'isoler qui s'avérait être un frein à
l'isolément pour beaucoup et je vous en
remercie
sur le deuxième volet celui de la
prévention
nous maintiendrons dans les mois à venir
certainement au moins jusqu'à l'été
prochain
un socle de mesures de protection comme
un filet de sécurité
bien entendu il s'agira d'abord par tous
les moyens pédagogiques institutionnel
de
appelez les gestes barrières et les
mesures de prévention dans notre
connaissance s'est amélioré au fil des
mois
respect de la distanciation port du
masque lavage des mains l'aération des
locaux etc
le respect de ses réflexes essentiel
restera restera nonobstant le
déploiement de la vaccination
une exigence pour chacune et chacun
d'entre nous et nous continuerons sans
relâche à sensibiliser informer à
communiquer sur tous les canaux
disponibles pour maintenir chez nos
concitoyens un haut niveau de vigilance
nous avons besoin de vous comme de
toutes les forces vives pour relayer
inlassablement ce message en particulier
avant les fêtes de fin d'année des
messages adaptés et des mesures
d'accompagnement ciblées devront aussi
être maintenue en direction des
personnes plus particulièrement
vulnérables au virus notamment dans le
cadre des plans métropolitain dont j'ai
sollicité de l'élaboration dès le début
du mois d'août dernier le déploiement de
la vaccination ne saurait à ce stade en
amoindrir la portée
nous maintiendrons également les
protocoles sanitaires couvrant le plus
grand nombre d'activités et
d'établissements possible ces protocoles
qui se sont précisées au fil des mois
peuvent être vous le savez durci en
fonction de l'intensité de l'épidémie le
large recours au télétravail qui a
prouvé son efficacité dans la lutte face
à la pandémie restera nécessaire
je tiens à saluer ici devant vous le
sens des responsabilités des partenaires
sociaux qui ont conclu le 26 novembre
dernier un accord sur le télétravail qui
clarifie les règles applicables en la
matière que ce soit pour les salariés ou
pour les employeurs
je sais que le recours au travail cinq
jours sur cinq peut entraîner des
difficultés organisationnelles et
surtout psychologique en fonction de
l'évolution épidémiologique et pour
tenir compte de ces effets le
télétravail pour être adaptées ainsi que
la ministre a évoqué avec les
partenaires sociaux
à compter du 7 janvier prochain enfin
reste à évoquer des mesures de freinage
nationale ou territorialisée dans leur
cour peut-être nécessaire dès lors que
les indicateurs épidémiologique et
hospitaliers sur le fondement de
critères qui se sentent sans cesse
affiné qui sont de plus en plus
transparents et partager franchi des
seuils traduisant une reprise une
augmentation de l'épidémie elles peuvent
être décidées sur une base localiser ou
concerner l'ensemble du territoire
lorsque la circulation virale devient
trop importante
ces mesures de freinage vous ne les
connaissez que trop elle vend de la
fermeture totale ou partielle d'activité
ou de catégories d'établissements
recevant du public aux restrictions de
circulation au couvre-feu voir jusqu'au
confinement il s'agit bien de mesures
préventives destinées à empêcher la
progression de la pandémie
ces mesures sont difficiles et souvent
ce qui est parfaitement compréhensible
mal acceptées elles sont pourtant
nécessaires et elles ont prouvé leur
efficacité en permettant à notre pays
d'afficher au cours du mois de novembre
le reflux le plus rapide le plus net de
l'épidémie en europe
je constate d'ailleurs avec vous que
certains de nos voisins ont choisi
quelques semaines après nous de mettre
en place un dispositif similaire au
nôtre
ces mesures appelle évidemment un
accompagnement
sans et adapté des secteurs
professionnels concernés
ce que mon gouvernement comme celui
demande prédécesseur n'a jamais hésité à
faire recueillant se faisant un large
soutien de la représentation nationale
ce qui est à l'honneur
mesdames et messieurs les députés de
notre pays dans les activités dans la
reprise avait été envisagé le 15
décembre
si les indicateurs sanitaires s'était
améliorée je pense notamment au cinéma
au théâtre salle de spectacle au musée
nous avons fixé une clause de revoyure
au 7 janvier à cette échéance nous
serons en mesure de vérifier les
premiers effets des vacances de fin
d'année sur la circulation virale et
nous aurons d'ici là mener avec la
ministre de la culture
les concertations nécessaires avec les
professionnels des secteurs concernés
mesdames et messieurs les députés en
présentant aujourd'hui devant votre
assemblée la stratégie vaccinale élaboré
par le gouvernement et plus généralement
la gestion globale de la gestion de la
crise qui continuera à s'appliquer
je souhaite partager avec vous toute
l'information dont nous disposons sur le
vaccin afin de nous permettre d'engager
un débat constructif
nous allons donc disposer d'une arme
supplémentaire pour vaincre ce virus
cette arme vous l'avez compris ici comme
ailleurs va monter en puissance
progressivement et il nous faut tout à
la fois être prudent patient mais
confiant la confiance ne se décrète pas
elle se gagne
elle se perd parfois mais surtout elle
se mérite
face à la peur
face aux doutes face à la suspicion
nous expliquerons autant qu'il le faudra
nous rassurons nous accompagnerons et
surtout nous protégerons transparence
totale vigilance absolue détermination
sans faille sauront mesdames et
messieurs les députés
nos maîtres mots dans cette campagne et
dans les semaines et les mois à venir
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
premier ministre
la parole est à monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
[Applaudissements]
merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés le premier
ministre vient à l'instant de présenter
notre stratégie vaccinale est à présent
je vais tenter de préciser quelques
éléments de calendrier des modalités
logistique ainsi que l'organisation de
l'association des parties prenantes
c'est une étape cruciale que nous
préparons dans la lutte contre cette
pandémie
une étape extrêmement exigeante une
étape qui demande de la rigueur beaucoup
de rigueur je sais que cette assemblée
ne manquera pas et je salue le travail
de l'office parlementaire d'évaluation
des choix scientifiques et
technologiques ne manquera pas de
rigueur pour le travail de grande
qualité qu'il a fournis et qui ne peut
qu'enrichir le débat à l'heure où la
science nous permet de franchir une
nouvelle étape dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie
c'était appel survient après de longs
mois d'une crise sanitaire qui a conduit
les pays du monde entier à prendre des
décisions au combien difficile et je
sais la fatigue je sais la lassitude que
ressentent nos concitoyens mais dans ce
contexte difficile l'arrivée de vaccins
- d'un an après le déclenchement de la
pandémie
c'est aussi un immense espoir est une
prouesse de la science ce sont aussi des
doutes que je ne veux pas éludé dans mon
propos au fond si je devais résumer la
campagne vaccinale qui va débuter je le
ferai en 3d fit le défi scientifique
tout d'abord depuis le début de cette
pandémie
la communauté scientifique pleinement
mobilisés bat tous les records
quelques semaines à peine pour
identifier un nouveau virus responsable
de troubles respiratoires sévères
jusqu'ici inconnu en tout cas pas anodin
c'était en chine
quelques jours à peine pour réaliser le
séquençage complet du génome du court
aux navires us et l institut pasteur qui
l'a fait qui reçoit un prélèvement le 24
janvier et qui le 28 janvier est en état
de séquencer ce virus et d'en partager
les données avec le monde entier c'était
en france moins d'un an donc pour
trouver et développer non pas un mais
bien plusieurs vaccins dont les
résultats publiés atteste d'une
efficacité remarquable
mesdames et messieurs les députés on ne
le dit pas suffisamment la science est
fantastique
la médecine est magnifique et plutôt que
d'en douter nous devrions collectivement
nous en féliciter et même le célébrer
nous avons nous avons oublié de rappeler
que dans la science il y à une aventure
qui se nouent et qu'à la naissance de
cette aventure scientifique il ya
souvent une idée une théorie un concept
un coup de génie
que ce soit dans un laboratoire où que
ce soit au pied du lit d'un malade dans
un hôpital
on a oublié de rappeler que la science
obéit à une rigueur à des protocoles de
recherche stricte évalué encadré normes
et la rigueur de la science face à
l'illusion que peut procurer la magie et
ses solutions simplistes et pourtant à
laquelle nombre de scientifiques aux
sceptiques se réfère pourtant souvent le
deuxième défi que nous avons il est
sociétale c'est le défi de la confiance
j'entends certains dire ce vaccin est
américain pourquoi aurais-je confiance
d'abord le vaccin n'est pas américain by
one tech est une société allemande qui
produit en belgique et qui s'est associé
à un grand laboratoire américain pour
être capable de produire dans le monde
entier des doses de vaccin j'entends que
le vaccin a été produit trop vite
je ne sais pas ce que ça veut dire trop
vite et là je mets une seconde la blouse
de neurologues moi qui fait face
régulièrement à des malades atteints de
maladies qu'on ne sait pas guérir ou
parfois qu'on a du mal à soigner
je ne me vois pas dire un jour ou un
traitement arriverez à mon malade vous
savez j'ai un peu peur de vous prescrire
ce traitement parce qu'il est arrivé
trop vite ou le traitement est évaluée
ils étaient prouvées il est efficace
alors c'est une chance pour les malades
ou il ne l'est pas et on n'offre pas aux
malades et on attend et on cherche un
autre traitement mais dès lors qu'on le
donne parce qu'il est efficace et qu'il
a été évalué ça reste une opportunité
pour les malades j'entends aussi le
vaccin arn messagers modifie le génome
humain le professeur alain fischer il ya
encore répondu ce matin sur une radio à
très juste titre un arn messagers
injecter ne modifient en aucun cas le
génome humain il est éliminé très vite
ne s'intègrent pas au génome j'entends
aussi quelque chose qu'on entend dans
d'autres campagnes de vaccination mouse
avait docteur g ou monsieur le ministre
le courant j'ai peur des adjuvants dans
le vaccin qui va être proposée par
laboratoire bio intake kaiser il n'ya
pas d'adjuvant il n'y a pas besoin d'un
jugement parce qu'il est suffisamment
efficace et immunogène et enfin
j'entends parfois des gens dire
finalement ce vaccin
est-ce qu'il sert pas juste engraisser
les labos est ce que finalement c'est
pas vous qui avait quasiment créé
l'épidémie temps et mesdames et
messieurs s'il n'y avait qu'un argument
opposé au complotisme ce serait celui du
coût du chômage partiel dans notre pays
la totalité des dépenses engendrées
générés par la campagne de vaccination à
l'échelle de toute l'europe représente
moins qu'une semaine de chômage partiel
dans notre pays donc il faut être
raisonnable répondre aux doutes quand il
y en a et si je devais résumer cela en
une phrase je citerai ce vieux dicton
populaire qui dit quand on veut tuer son
chien on dit qu'il a la rage
le paradoxe dans le pays de pasteur qui
a lui-même inventé le vaccin contre la
rage
donc faisons attention et portant la
parole scientifique avec confiance et
crédit
je rappelle à ce sujet un point
absolument essentiel ce n'est pas le
gouvernement ni français ni américain ni
allemand ni belle ni chinois ni russe ni
je ne sais de quelle origine qui a mis
au point le vaccin
de la même manière si aucun gouvernement
qui aurait créé ce virus le gouvernement
français il a un objectif faire en sorte
que la vaccination se passe bien c'est
le bon vaccin au bon patient au bon
endroit au bon moment
ce sont les scientifiques ce sont les
autorités sanitaires indépendante
française européenne qui nous disent si
le vaccin est efficace ou s'il donnait
pas s'il est sûr ou s'il ne l'est pas
dans quelles conditions nous sommes
amenés à pouvoir l'utiliser auprès de
quel malade dans quel ordre
ce n'est pas une décision politique
c'est une orientation sanitaire
scientifiques indépendantes et je le
redis et notre rôle c'est de veiller à
ce que les choses se passent bien et
c'est là l'objet du troisième et dernier
défi sur lequel je vais m'atteler à
répondre qui est le défi logistique la
stratégie nationale de la stratégie
nationale de vaccination a pour objectif
principal de faire nous le savons
baisser la mortalité et les formes
graves de la maladie de protéger les
français et de garantir la sécurité
sanitaire de tous les malades de tous
les français
cette stratégie s'appuie sur les
recommandations de la haute autorité de
santé relative à la stratégie de
priorisation des populations à vacciner
contre le coc vide
elle comporte plusieurs étapes dont la
première doit débuter très prochainement
cette première étape c'est un premier
public c'est un public dont nous savons
qu'il est éminemment prioritaire parce
que plus vulnérables face à la maladie
parce qu'il est public le plus fragile
face au virus
et parce qu'il est en même temps le plus
exposé je veux bien sûr parler des
personnes âgées dans les établissements
et les hébergements de longue durée dans
les services de long séjour dans les
unités de soins de longue durée en
priorité mais aussi dans d'autres lieux
d'hébergement comme les résidences
autonomie les résidences services
protéger ces personnes vulnérables nos
aînés en perte d'autonomie c'est aussi
protéger les femmes et les hommes qui
les accompagnent au quotidien
c'est pourquoi je suivant les
recommandations de la haute autorité de
santé
nous proposerons la vaccination aux
professionnels travaillant dans ces
établissements
lorsqu'ils présentent eux-mêmes un
risque accru de formes graves ou de
décès qu'ils aient plus de 65 ans ou
qu'ils présentent des facteurs de
comorbidité des précisions seront
fournis dans un avis complémentaire de
la haute autorité de santé
l'ensemble des personnes qui pourraient
être concernées par cette première étape
c'est environ un million de français un
million c'est un défi en soi mais nous
pouvons faire confiance à nos soignants
pour arriver à relever ce défi
c'est la priorité des priorités quand le
virus rentrer dans un ehpad
ils s'arrêtent rarement à une seule
personne et nous avons suffisamment
constater et déplorer des clusters qui
ont pu coûter la vie à des dizaines de
résidents des ehpad
je me souviens d'ailleurs la décision la
plus difficile que j'ai eu à prendre
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
c'était la suspension des visites en
établissement pour personnes âgées pour
rien au monde pour rien au monde
nous nous voulons revivre cette
situation je veux redire aux
professionnels du grand âge mon immense
gratitude parce que dans cette période
si compliqué ils ont répondu présent et
croyez moi avec brigitte bourguignon
ministre délégué à l'autonomie nous ne
ménageons pas nos efforts au quotidien
pour être en contact permanent avec les
résidents et les soignants dans les
ehpad
c'est une première étape qui sera
décisif mais les personnels des
établissements pour personnes âgées ne
seront pas seuls pour l'affranchir ils
seront informés en avance les ars se
tiendront à leurs côtés pour que
l'approvisionnement se déroule dans les
meilleures conditions
il y aura ensuite la deuxième étape
selon le rythme de livraison des
différents vaccins
elle va concerner les gens par catégorie
d'âge cette fois ci donc les plus de 75
ans puis les plus de 65 ans et enfin les
plus de 50 ans avec les personnels de
santé et du secteur médico-social
lorsqu'ils sont âgés de 50 ans et plus
haut qu'il présente des comorbidités
après hallyday revient le printemps et
nous pourrons alors étendre
progressivement la stratégie de
vaccination au grand public
il y aura les personnes âgées de 50 à 64
ans
une partie importante de la population
il y aura les professionnels des
secteurs essentiels au fonctionnement du
pays en période épidémique dans le
secteur de la sécurité de l'éducation
des secteurs alimentaires elle
concernera également les publics
vulnérables et précaires ainsi que les
professionnels qui les prennent en
charge les personnes qui vivent dans des
hébergements confiné où des lieux clos
puis le reste de la population majeure
pour ces étapes nous nous appuierons sur
celles et ceux qui fondent le socle de
notre système de santé
ceux en qui les français ont confiance
plus quand nous puisqu'on nous mais
quand vous c'est à dire les
professionnels de santé en ville et en
particulier les médecins vous le voyez
nous sommes bel et bien entrée dans
l'organisation de la campagne vaccinale
est très prochainement son déploiement
cela constitue je le redis un défi
logistique immense et j'ajouterais même
historique dans les échelles sont sans
comparaison avec nos traditions
vaccinale la première étape de la
campagne correspondra à l'utilisation de
ce premier vaccin donc dont je parlais
le finder by one tech sous réserve
évidemment du feu vert donné par les
autorités sanitaires je rappelle même si
c'est une évidence dans notre pays que
les vaccins comme il sont traités avec
le même niveau d'exigence que tous les
autres médicaments autorisés en europe
de manière à garantir leur sécurité
une fois l'autorisation de mise sur le
marché obtenu par les laboratoires c'est
ensuite la haute autorité de santé qui
donne son avis sur chacun des vaccins
elle va ainsi précisé dans quels cas ce
vaccin sera indiquée contre indiqués au
plan individuel en fonction des données
scientifiques qui lui sont propres
vous le savez ça a été évoqué nous
attendons un avis de l'agencé du
médicament européenne qui pourrait
intervenir le 21 décembre
la livraison des premiers vaccins
pourraient intervenir dans le même
mouvement pour le pays
nous attendons ensuite un avis de la
commission européenne et je remercie
énormément clément boon qui qui
travaille aux affaires européennes et
qui travaillent sur ces questions-là
d'arrache-pied commission européenne
pourrait valider l'utilisation du vaccin
en europe le
3 décembre après quoi il y aura la vie
de ce qu'on appelle la commission
technique des vaccinations de la haute
autorité de santé qui pourrait
intervenir le 24
probablement pas le 25 chacun comprendra
est peut-être le 24 et le 26 le 27 ou le
28 décembre
auquel cas et avec une coopération
européenne et une coordination sur les
modes d'entrée de la vaccination
nous pourrions commencer à vacciner les
premiers malades en france comme l'a dit
le premier ministre avant la fin de
l'année 2020 dans les derniers jours de
décembre
je veux également rappelé que nous
mettons en place pour tous les vaccins
qu'ovide un dispositif de
pharmacovigilance renforcée afin de
suivre en temps réel et au niveau
individuel toutes les suspicions
d'éventuels effets indésirables gelé
résume brièvement il y aura des plans de
gestion des risques mis en place par les
laboratoires c'est une obligation qui
leur est faite
un dispositif de suivi renforcé à la
haine smc l' agence du médicament c'est
son métier qui centralisera les données
remontées du terrain sur le suivi des
patients et les effets indésirables et
qui fera une analyse quotidienne des
nouveaux cas une possibilité de
signalements par les citoyens sera
ouverte par ailleurs la 1e publiera
régulièrement sur son site internet les
résultats de ce suivi
troisième pilier de la vigilance des
études spécifiques seront effectués par
la rsm et l'assurance maladie pour
compléter les connaissances sur les
risques de survenue des événements
indésirables et enfin deux autres
systèmes complémentaires de suivi sont
mis en place en parallèle un par
l'inserm qui évaluera l'impact de la
vaccination en vie réelle en suivant des
cohortes de patients et un autre par
santé publique france qui organisera un
suivi de l'efficacité de la vaccination
en comparant les risques d'attraper le
virus entre les populations vaccinées et
non vaccinés vous voyez c'est un arsenal
complet de dispositifs de suivi qui est
mis en place nécessaire pour que la
confiance soit maximale revient à la
première étape et aux caractéristiques
spécifiques de ce vaccin
celui de pfizer baïona ntech c'est un
bien précieux qui doit être transporter
et stocker avec un soin autant vous le
dire tout particulier d'abord il
requiert un stockage à moins 80 degrés
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement a d'ores
et déjà acheté et qualifiés des
congélateurs spécifique adapté équipés
de systèmes d'information haddock qui
sont installés progressivement dans de
nombreux points du territoire afin que
le vaccin puisse être
apportez stocker temporairement avant la
livraison finale il faut en effet gagner
du temps parce que dès qu'on à
décongeler ce vaccin qui n'est plus à
-80 et qu ils se conservent alors entre
2 et 8 degrés eh bien nous avons cinq
jours pour pouvoir réaliser la
vaccination effective des patients et ça
ne suffisait pas en terme de complexité
lebrun darren messager qui composent ce
vaccin est suffisamment fragile pour que
nous ne puissions pas dépasser 12 heures
de transport entre le moment où les
décongeler et le moment où il est
injecté aux patients 12 heures de
transport maximum avec toutes les étapes
c'est une grosse logistique je le disais
tout à l'heure je vous parle d'
établissements collectifs nous parlons
de plus de dix mille établissements
collectifs recevant des personnes âgées
pour relever ce défi nous avons fait le
choix de nous appuyer sur les
compétences existantes et éprouvée dans
notre pays et sur la connaissance des
pharmaciens avec lesquelles les
établissements ont l'habitude de
travailler
nous avons évidemment acheter en avance
tout le matériel de vaccination et de
reconstitutions je parle notamment des
seringue des aiguilles mais aussi des
gants pour manipuler des produits à
moins 80 degrés je vous fais grâce du
reste au regard des temps de transport
que je viens d'évoquer
il convient de s'assurer que les doses
pourront être administré rapidement
après leur livraison au sein
d'établissements accueillant des
personnes âgées ce qui rend nécessaire
une planification très fine et anticiper
des circuits de livraison et une
anticipation des campagnes de
vaccination au sein de ces
établissements
l'organisation de la campagne de
vaccination reposera d'abord sur la
réalisation de consultations pré
vaccinale réalisées prioritairement par
les médecins traitants parce qu'ils en
ont l'habitude
les médecins recevront une information
claire et complète sur le vaccin son
efficacité ses contre indications
éventuelles
cette information a déjà commencé et
elle sera complétée à l'issue de
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché et
de la vie qui devrait intervenir à la
fin du mois de décembre elle sera
approfondie ce vendredi sur la base des
premières publications étrangères et en
présence du professeur alain fischer
ensuite le jour de la vaccination un
dernier examen permettra d'évaluer
l'état de la personne avant la
vaccination qui devrait s'effectuer en
présence d'un médecin monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés je crois aux vertus de
l'explication de la pédagogie et de la
rigueur scientifique
la has a donné un avis extrêmement
précis
sur la stratégie vaccinale qui définit
le public prioritaire
un avis qui est indépendante je le redis
et nous avons fait le choix de suivre
cet avis c'est notre méthode vous
appuyez sur ceux dont c'est le métier
permettez moi pour conclure de mettre
l'accent sur cette méthode
notre stratégie vaccinale ne
fonctionnera qu'au prix d'une
mobilisation générale
c'est un défi je les dis mais ce n'est
pas le défi du gouvernement
c'est un défi collectif c'est le défi de
toute une nation
c'est le sens même de la tenue de ce
débat devant la représentation nationale
et pour surmonter ce défi nous
travaillons en équipe
dès le lancement de la phase
d'organisation cet automne j'ai demandé
à mon équipe d'organiser une
concertation extrêmement large plus de
40 réunion de prise de contact et
d'information en toute transparence avec
les différents professionnels de santé
j'ai ensuite souhaité que des comités de
suivi hebdomadaire soit organisé au sein
du ministère avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes jeu réunit toutes les semaines
les représentants des professionnels de
santé les ordres les syndicats au sein
d'un comité des professions de santé
puisque ce sont eux qui seront en
première ligne une fois encore ainsi que
les représentants des hospitaliers avec
les fédérations les conférences de
directeurs les présidents de commission
médicale d'établissement
j'ai réuni en fin de semaine dernière
plusieurs milliers de médecins en
visioconférence quand je dis plusieurs
milliers de médecins il y avait
exactement 19800 médecins qui ont
répondu à l'appel grâce à l'ordre
national des médecins de manière à
échanger à bâtons rompus pendant une
heure sur les questions qui pouvaient
être posée est par ailleurs avec
brigitte bourguignon nous échangeons
toutes les semaines avec les
représentants des établissements pour
personnes âgées qui vont dans les
prochaines semaines
jouer un rôle absolument capital je vous
le dis ici sans ambages je ne crois pas
que nous pourrons créer l'adhésion des
français sur la vaccination et vous
savez combien nos concitoyens sont
exigeants sur ce sujet sans nous appuyer
sur les communautés médicales
paramédicales et scientifique
je sais aussi que notre stratégie serait
bien peu de chose sans l'appui et
l'engagement des élus locaux
je tiens avec mes équipes un comité des
élus tous les quinze jours qui permet de
partager toutes les informations et
d'associer pleinement les collectivités
au déploiement de notre stratégie
qu'il s'agisse de s'appuyer sur leur
connaissance fine de leur territoire sur
les ressources dont elle dispose
ou tout simplement sur la confiance et
l'adhésion dont disposent les élus
locaux vous le savez
pouvoir dire que nous travaillons en
confiance et ceci est précieux les
collectivités en main dans la main avec
les agences régionales de santé les
préfectures un rôle majeur à jouer dans
cette campagne de vaccination et ce dès
la première étape est encore plus
important pour les étapes suivantes
c'est pourquoi seront mises en place au
niveau local des cellules territoriales
de suivi suivi de la vaccination
associant les services de l'état les
collectivités territoriales et les
professionnels de santé
enfin puisque j'ai parlé de mobilisation
générale je ne peux pas ne pas évoquer
la coordination européenne qui a marqué
ces dernières semaines l'europe s'est
montrée unie soudée ambitieuse pour
préparer de manière efficace cette
campagne vaccinale historique avec mes
homologues allemands belges espagnols
italiens luxembourgeois néerlandais mais
également suisse nous avons échangé
encore hier dans un esprit constructif
et solidaire et nous sommes convenus de
poursuivre ensemble l'objectif d'un
lancement coordonné de nos campagnes
vaccinales
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés les coureurs de
fond savent qu'un marathon ne commence
vraiment qu aux alentours du 30e
kilomètre
c'est à ce moment que l'on appelle le
mur que se joue toute la course alors je
ne sais pas encore à quelle km nous
trouvons dans cette course mais je sais
que nous arrivons dans cette zone
décisive où l'on doit se remobiliser
pleinement malgré la fatigue et malgré
la lassitude
alors nous allons avancer ensemble nous
allons mettre un pied devant l'autre de
façon déterminée en étant prudent en
étant transparent et surtout en étant
confiant je vous remercie
merci monsieur lune
la parole est à monsieur gérard le seul
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
pour dix minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
s'il annonce de vaccins mise sur le
marché il ya quelques semaines laissent
envisager une sortie de crise
progressive dans les mois qui viennent
les défis à relever les questions liées
à la stratégie vaccinale n'en demeure
pas moins considérable pouvoir en
débattre et essentielle s'était
d'ailleurs l'objet de l'alinéa 12 de la
proposition de résolution du groupe
socialiste apparentés déposé le 12
novembre dernier à l'initiative de notre
résidant de valérie rabault monsieur le
ministre vous ne l'avez dit la stratégie
de vaccination doit relever de nombreux
défis sociétaux scientifiques médicaux
de logistique économique
j'aimerais ici remercier le président de
l'assemblée nationale qui s'est engagé
pour que l'office parlementaire des
choix scientifiques puissent se jouer
tout son rôle de contrôle et
d'évaluation au pied levé une mission
bicaméral de députés de sénatrice a vu
le jour coordonné par son président
cédric villani que je salue au passage
cela a permis hier de présenter un
rapport d'étape
cela permet aussi d'apprécier le long
chemin qui reste à parcourir pour
réussir la stratégie vaccinale que vous
venez de nous présenter cette stratégie
vaccinale s'appuie aujourd'hui sur
plusieurs éléments liés à la
connaissance du virus et de la maladie
on sait que le taux de létalité var et
surtout en fonction de l'âge et augmente
jusqu'à 8 % en moyenne pour les plus de
80 ans dès lors la recommandation de la
haute autorité de santé que vous avez
rappelé de procéder par vaccination
progressive par phases en priorisant les
publics âgés et où les plus fragiles par
des facteurs de morbidité apparaît
raisonnable
cependant il ya un premier point qui ne
favorise pas la bonne compréhension par
nos concitoyens et par le et par les
parlementaires des décisions prises
la multiplication des cellules et autres
conseils de sécurité opacifie la prise
de décision au lieu de simplifier la
coordination qui prend les décisions de
ce premier ministre avec quels conseils
dans quelle transparence
comment s'articulent les organismes de
conseil et d'expert qui vous
accompagnent dans la prise de décision
l'articulation de tous ces conseils
n'apparaît pas très lisible ni aux
parlementaires ni aux concitoyens
il apparaît donc nécessaire de clarifier
les rôles et missions tous ces
organismes et d'en rendre la lecture
intelligible pour les françaises et les
français
la bonne performance de la chaîne
logistique est une condition majeure de
la réussite de la stratégie vaccinale
le défi est extrêmement ardu dès la
première phase de vaccins
nation compte tenu des contraintes de
transport et de manipulation du vaccin
qui sera disponible le message officiel
se veut rassurant mais nous manquons
précisions sur les modalités pratiques
qui seront mises en oeuvre notamment
concernant la logistique du dernier
kilomètre
les français ont besoin d'informations
précises national mais aussi régional et
local sur le stockage la distribution
des vaccins dans le respect des
conditions de conservation des lots la
réalisation des vaccinations qui devront
rester optionnel et recueillir le libre
consentement des personnes devra
s'appuyer vous l'avez dit sur des
professionnels de santé de proximité qui
ont une relation privilégiée de
connaissances et de confiance avec leur
patientèle il faudra d'ailleurs à ce
propos
encore que ces professionnels de santé
dispose des informations nécessaires sur
le vaccin proposé ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui
il faudra aussi construire un système
d'informations simples et complets afin
de tracer l'ensemble des vaccinations
opérer et sans doute mettre en place le
carnet de vaccination électronique est
remonté en temps réel les aventures des
effets indésirables
parmi les défis bien un qui conditionne
la réussite de tous les autres c'est la
décision individuelle et collective de
se faire vacciner est votre stratégie
doit obtenir du plus grand nombre non
seulement qu'ils puissent mais qu'il
veuille bien se faire vacciner
or la défiance aujourd'hui constitue un
facteur majeur de limitation des changes
du réussite de votre statut stratégie de
vaccination
paradoxalement au pays de pasteur
effectivement il ya une résistance
historique dans la vaccination d'ordre
religieux naturaliste intérêt
scientifique complotistes peu importe
aujourd'hui il me semble que
l'hésitation voir la réticence vaccinale
et la défiance qui se sont installés
depuis plusieurs mois trouve
majoritairement leurs racines dans la
gestion brouillonne de cette crise par
votre gouvernement
les dysfonctionnements cafouillage
approximations du printemps anime encore
douloureusement les discussions
familiales les informations dissimulées
voire les mensonges autour des masques
l'absence de discours de vérité
la capacité à assurer le triptyque
tester tracé isolés ont inquiété des
châtiments nos concitoyens et je ne
parlerai pas des vaccins antigrippaux
qui ne sont jamais arrivées
monsieur le premier ministre les mesures
de confinement à géométrie variable qui
traite différemment les salles de cultes
des salles de culture les commerces
essentiel des commerces malheureusement
qualifié de non essentiels sont
incomprises sont incomprises monsieur
premier ministre et c'est à ce point
compris que ça nuit à la crédibilité de
la parole politique
vous auriez dû monsieur le premier
ministre davantage travailler avec les
élus locaux comme ils vous l'avez
demandé à plusieurs reprises ici dans
cet hémicycle
nous avons réclamé un dialogue préfet
maire pour que puisse être accepté les
mesures de confinement des activités
commerciales
résultat selon un sondage ou doxa du
mois de novembre 42% des français font
confiance au gouvernement pour faire
face à l'épidémie en cours
la perte de confiance dans les
institutions publiques est sans nul
doute la raison majeure qui éclaire la
hausse récente de la résistance
vaccinale en france plus grande
malheureusement que dans les autres pays
européens a donc la réussite de votre
stratégie passera par une concertation
avec tous les professionnels de la santé
les dialogues avec les corps
intermédiaires et tous les citoyens
le premier remède contre la défiance
c'est la transparence vous l'avez dit
les questions d'indépendance des acteurs
de la stratégie vaccinale à l'égard des
intérêts privés sont souvent posées
c'est pourquoi il est important que vous
puissiez apporter des réponses précises
sur la prévention des risques ou la
prévention des conflits d'intérêt
notamment en mettant en place une
déclaration obligatoire des intérêts
privés des personnes concernées et
active dans les différents comités
lisez les réseaux sociaux reçu le
premier ministre je vous assure
de même il n'est pas normal que seule
une poignée de députés européens soit
autorisé à consulter les contrats passés
entre l'union européenne et des
laboratoires et pour les consulter ils
doivent être habilités et se présenter
sans téléphone ni stylo comment dans ces
conditions parler de vraie transparence
alors je le demande en nommant groupe
monsieur le premier ministre
rendez public l'ensemble de ces
documents pour éviter d'alimenter les
discours de méfiance et de défiance
instituer un registre public national ou
européen des contrats signés
la transparence n'est pas un acte de foi
elle doit être mise en oeuvre
complètement en dépassant les
incantations l'action l'axé pardon à
l'information scientifique médical
pharmacologique économiques doivent
également être facilités
c'est d'ailleurs une recommandation
forte de la mission d'évaluation de la
stratégie vaccinale l'acceptabilité
passe par l'accessibilité de
l'information la communication devra
donc porter clairement sur les vaccins
leurs éventuels effets secondaires et
les nouvelles technologies mises en
oeuvre des vaccins à aménager messages
et les doutes exprimés par nos
concitoyens avant d'aborder cette
nouvelle étape sont légitimes monsieur
le ministre il est normal de
s'interroger
lorsque quelque chose de nouveau
apparaît le doute
c'est même le principe de la science il
faut respecter tous ceux qui doutent
quelles que soient leurs raisons et ce
toutes appellent des réponses précises
clair il faut dire clairement ce que
l'on sait ce que l'on ne sait pas et ne
rien cacher à la population la
vaccination peut apparaître comme une
solution progressive et efficace avec
les sanitaires que nous vivons depuis
des mois nous souhaitons tous et je
pense comme vous tous à toutes celles et
tous ceux qui sont frappés par la
maladie ou par les conséquences
économiques et sociales de cette crise
sanitaire
la responsabilité impose un discours de
vérité
les spécialistes sont formels votre
professeur alain fischer qui préside le
conseil d'orientation la sirn aussi si
l'efficacité du vaccin de pfizer est
avérée pour éviter le développement des
formes graves
rien ne permet d'affirmer aujourd'hui
que les vaccins aujourd'hui sur le match
les permettront d'empêcher la
transmission du virus il faut donc que
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens soient
bien informés il faut également tirer
toutes les conséquences de la mauvaise
stratégie vaccinale adoptée au moment du
vaccin h1n1
les médecins avaient été mis de côté des
grands lieux avaient été réquisitionnés
pour vacciner
résultat le lien de confiance était
altéré alors monsieur le premier
ministre nous venons d'apprendre que la
date initialement indiqué par l' agence
européenne du médicament qui doit
autoriser le vaccin donnerait son
autorisation en début de semaine
prochaine ce qui devrait permettre à
notre propre autorité nationale
d'accélérer son processus et de valider
à son tour la mission de marché national
du vaccin
il apparaît néanmoins cependant
souhaitable que le gouvernement
n'accélère pas inutilement sa date de
déploiement
car les aspects logistiques l'éthique du
consentement de la communication pour
une bonne acceptabilité de la démarche
ne sont pas encore au point
et s'il est symboliquement important que
la date de vaccination soit identique
dans tous les pays européens
il est aussi important que ceux ci
soient disponibles en tout point du
territoire en même temps en métropole en
outre mer on peut le regretter votre
gouvernement aurait dû se préparer bien
plus tôt mais malheureusement nous
doutons fortement que cela puisse être
le cas fin décembre que bon comme vous
venez de le dire
enfin je terminerais monsieur le
président par un regret une folle
nous n'aurons pas de vaccin français
avant de nombreux mois et je pense que
la seule conclusion nous pouvons tirer
c'est la faiblesse du soutien financier
que nous avons apportées en france
contrairement à nos confrères européens
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur thomas gaccio
pour le groupe agir ensemble pour cinq
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues nous
débattons cet après-midi de notre
stratégie vaccinale contre la copie de
pour commencer je voudrais dire que
cette crise a trop souvent été
l'occasion d'un mauvais procès à nos
démocraties la propagande de certains
états a pu donner le sentiment durant un
certain temps que notre modèle et nos
principes étaient peu zine peu adapté
pour faire face à la pandémie mondiale
non seulement c'est faux quand on prend
le temps d'une analyse internationale
sur l'efficacité des modes de gestion de
la crise mais par ailleurs la production
rapide de ces vaccins qu'ovide nous
prouver également contraire car ils sont
bien le fruit d'un travail de
coopération de recherche et de
développement industriel sans précédent
rendu possible par le bon fonctionnement
de nos démocraties
enfin pour la première fois les pays
européens ont fait le choix du collectif
dans la mise à disposition des vaccins
le dernier conseil européen en fin de
semaine dernière a par ailleurs rappelé
l'importance d'une coordination des
stratégies de vaccination et aujourd'hui
nous pouvons saluer l'engagement de tous
ceux qui travaillent dans l'industrie de
santé
j'ai une pensée particulière pour les
collaborateurs qui travaillent dans ma
circonscription sur le site sanofi de
marcy l'étoile
dans la lignée de pasteur dont le
premier vaccin fut inoculé il y à 135
ans et je rappellerai à notre collègue
le seul que le président était venu le
président de la république était venu en
juin annoncée en soutien de 200 millions
d'euros à la filière industrielle pour
le développement justement en matière de
vaccins 200 millions d'euros qui
s'ajoutaient aux 600 millions d'euros
d'investissements annoncés par sanofi il
reste que le recours au vaccin suscite
chez nos concitoyens le plus souvent de
bonne foi de nombreux doutes comme le
dit le texte dont chalut ici la
remarquable qualité des travaux
l'hésitation vaccinale se présente sous
la forme d'un continuum allant du refus
pur et simple de toute vaccination à une
prudence
une prudence un peu plus raisonnée fondé
la plupart du temps sur un déficit
d'information
les questions de nos concitoyens sont
nombreuses est-ce que les vaccins
coville vont permettre d'éviter la
transmission du virus ou simplement
d'éviter les formes graves de la maladie
leurs effets seront utiles durable y
aura-t-il des effets secondaires faut-il
vacciner y compris
personnes ayant déjà été testée kobe de
plus enfin faudra-t-il rendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour cents
certaines catégories de personnes par
exemple les personnels des ehpad
dans ce contexte le groupe agir ensemble
se réjouit que la représentation
nationale prenne toute sa part au débat
sur la stratégie vaccinale car votre
déclaration monsieur le premier ministre
et ce débat doivent contribuer à
présenter l'état des connaissances sur
les vaccins avec transparence et clarté
afin non seulement de prendre les
décisions les bonnes décisions pour
notre pays mais aussi de rassurer nos
concitoyens et nous vous remercions
monsieur le premier ministre votre
mobilisation et partageons votre
stratégie vaccinale progressive en
priorisant les publics les plus fragiles
est fondée sur la balance bénéfices
risques nous partageons également
pleinement la décision de laisser le
libre choix de se faire vacciner ou non
car dans nos démocraties pour réussir
collectivement il faut d'abord
convaincre enfin nous rappelons la
nécessité d'associer étroitement les
médecins généralistes les pharmaciens
ont des infirmiers qui sont les plus
proches de leurs patients et d'assurer
également la traçabilité et le suivi des
effets indésirables
l'inscription systématique de la
vaccination dans le carnet de santé
électronique y contribuerait et serait
l'occasion d'en développer les usages
pour un suivi durable des vaccinations
si ces vaccins sont un espoir pour toute
l'humanité qui espèrent-ils voilerie
voir le bout du tunnel qu'ovide nous
invitons toutefois à la prudence
et pour plusieurs raisons premièrement
ils ne semblent pas aujourd'hui garanti
à ce stade que les vaccins empêche son
porteur de propager le virus
le maintien des gestes barrières et du
port du masque nous semble donc
indispensable y compris pour les
personnes vaccinées
nous n'avons pas non plus de certitudes
sur la durabilité de l'efficacité de ces
vaccins
les premières phases vont constituer des
tests cliniques grandeur nature enfin
pour être efficace un taux de couverture
vaccinale supérieur à 60 70 % est
nécessaire
chers collègues pour y parvenir il
faudra probablement attendre au moins
jusqu'au second semestre 2021
les incertitudes qui entourent les
vaccins contre la queue 8,19 sont donc
encore nombreuses mais ces vaccins sont
incontestablement un progrès majeur dans
la lutte contre la pandémie
c'est pourquoi le groupe agir ensemble
soutient la stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement mais au delà nous appelons
à poursuit
les actions pour rendre notre société
plus résiliente sur plan sanitaire non
seulement pour accélérer la sortie de
cette crise mais aussi pour se préparer
pour se préparer pour se préparer aux
prochaines car oui mes chers collègues
malheureusement d'autres crises
surviendront et cette fois il faudra
être prêt merci chers collègues
la parole est au volant bolivie 6 pour
le groupe
udi indépendant pour dix minutes
monsieur le président ce premier
ministre messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues notre groupe souhaite
tout d'abord salué l'initiative du
gouvernement nous permettant de débattre
de la stratégie vaccinale dans cette
assemblée
je crois que sur ses bancs nous avons à
s'exprimer notre frustration car nous ne
pouvions discuter de la stratégie du
gouvernement pour lutter contre la copie
de 19 et tu en as train d'autres débats
sans rapport direct avec la première des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens
à l'heure où plusieurs laboratoires
présente peur vaccin que les autorités
sanitaires font leur travail de
certification et que dans certains pays
les vaccinations commencer je me réjouie
qu'enfin la représentation nationale
puisse s'exprimer
je voudrais également remercier le
travail effectué par notre collègue
cédric villani au sein de l'opex qui a
mené une série d'auditions la semaine
dernière sur la stratégie vaccinale
largement ouverte à l'ensemble des
députés sénateurs
la deuxième vague qui semble d'une
ampleur au moins équivalente à la
première balle et nos certitudes même
l'allemagne dans la gestion de
l'épidémie semble exemplaire connaît des
difficultés
la suède qui prône le concept de
l'immunité collective doit aujourd'hui
faire face elle aussi à une envolée du
nombre de contaminations et demain
preuve qu aucun pays et aucune stratégie
ne prémunit totalement sa population de
cette menace et que dire des états unis
où les fêtes de thanksgiving a entraîné
une circulation exponentielle de la
circulation du virus en 24 heures les
etats-unis ont déploré plus demeure de
mort qu'il n'y en a eu lors des
attentats du 11 septembre
cette incertitude avec laquelle il nous
faut composer ne se comptent pas
seulement en nombre de contaminations et
de mort car beaucoup de nos concitoyens
touchés par le cos vide conservent des
séquelles
certains autres n'ont pas été touchés
directement par le virus nous ont été
affectés par la dépression la solitude
l'angoissent conséquences des mesures
pour limiter la diffusion du virus
face au fléau qui nous accable la
perspective d'un vaccin apparaît comme
la lumière au bout du tunnel
mais encore faut-il que la campagne
vaccinale soit un succès ce dont nous
pouvons nous réjouir c'est du rôle joué
par l'europe dans cette stratégie
vaccinale l'union européenne d
montre depuis des semaines que notre
idéal européen prend tout son sens grâce
à l'europe
nous avons été en capacité de mettre en
commun nos ressources pour se doter de
millions de doses tout en faisant
d'importantes économies d'échelle
l'europe nous assure de la fiabilité des
vaccins grâce au travail de l'agencé
européenne du médicament
l'europe permet à chaque européen de
bénéficier de manière équitable des
doses mise sur le marché tout en
assurant que chaque état membre soit
mise à contribution dans leur production
l'europe n'a pas été lente ni
bureaucratique et encore moins hors sol
elle a su faire son oeuvre pour protéger
sa population garantir la solidarité
entre ses membres et à terme permettre à
chaque européen d'avoir accès au vaccin
finalement ce nom nous avons
collectivement besoin c'est de
l'application stricte du principe de
subsidiarité prendre les décisions au
bon échelon réservons à l'europe les
négociations avec les états et aux
territoires l'organisation locale
permettant l'accès au vaccin
notre groupe milite depuis des années
pour la thériault territorialisation de
notre système de santé
d'ailleurs durant l'examen du dernier
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale
nous avons proposé au gouvernement la
création d'un budget régional de la
santé par la mise en place d'un ordre
dames la déclinaison territoriale de la
stratégie vaccinale nécessite que l'état
fasse confiance au territoire et à nos
élus qu'ils connaissent mieux que
personne leur territoire et par
conséquent la meilleure manière
d'administrer le vaccin au plus grand
nombre
notre groupe s'interroge également sur
le conditionnement du vaccin
le maintien du produit à très basse
température constitue-t-il selon vous un
obstacle à l'implication la médecine de
ville ou des officines de pharmacie nous
considérons qu'en matière d'association
des élus et des citoyens la stratégie
vaccinale
nous ne pouvons pas nous satisfaire de
la création de comité ad-hoc
le tirage au sort d'élus ou de citoyens
pour intégrer un comité ne saurait
constituer un gage de la représentation
pardon de la représentativité de la
nation n'est une forme de caution de
quelconques consultation
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat sont
ont toute leur légitimité dans les
représenter
sur nationale et de nos territoires
monsieur le premier ministre
écouter les parlementaires et appuyez
vous sur nous pour relayer votre
stratégie vaccinale sur les territoires
la déclinaison territoriale de la
stratégie vaccinale est une des
conditions de son succès la confiance en
est une autre
un certain nombre de nos concitoyens
expriment une forme de défiance envers
les nouveaux vaccins développés ils ont
bien compris que la diffusion d' avec 5
contres lakovic 19 serait une manne
financière colossale et ils craignent
que les laboratoires privilégie les
retombées économiques à la santé
publique
ces inquiétudes sont légitimes ils font
donc les hantent les entendre mais tel
que l'expliqué le professeur fisher
président du conseil d'orientation des
stratégies vaccinales
qu'importe la rapidité avec laquelle les
vaccins ont été développés les agences
du médicament européenne et française
n'en néglige rompt pas pour autant leur
travail de certification
si ces vaccins sont mis sur le marché
cela veut dire qu'ils sont aussi fiables
que les vaccins qui ont déjà été
administrées nos concitoyens une part de
la population s'exprime ouvertement
opposés à la vaccination
il nous appartient de convaincre ces
français de les responsabiliser
car comme le dit un des infectiologues
de l'institut pasteur de lille sur mana
sur mon département daniel camus la
personne qui ose dire c'est ma liberté
de ne pas me faire vacciner
ça veut dire qu'elle compte sur les
autres pour empêcher la circulation du
virus
pour autant il convient de susciter
cette confiance d'inciter les français
sans l'assortir d'une obligation à se
faire vacciner
l'enjeu est de faire comprendre aux
français que se faire vacciner un acte
citoyen je le fais pour me protéger et
pour protéger les autres cela nous
permettra collectivement de retrouver
une vie sociale une vie culturelle
nous pourrions aussi prendre exemple sur
l'israël qui octroie à chaque personne
vaccinée un passeport vers leur
permettant de se rendre dans des lieux
de culture au restaurant en définitive
de retrouver une vie normale
notre groupe considère qu'une telle
mesure serait de nature à inciter les
français à se faire vacciner et à faire
prendre conscience que la vaccination
permet de se protéger soi même mais
également autrui
après la déclinaison territoriale et la
confiance
le dernier point pour que cette campagne
vaccinale tête un succès selon nous
c'est la souveraineté industrielle la
destruction et la fuite à l'étranger de
notre capacité de production
industrielle nous handicape encore
aujourd'hui alors de lutter contre la
crise sanitaire le vaccin du laboratoire
pfizer devant être conservé une
température de moins 70 degrés il nous
faudra commander un certain nombre de
congélateurs à très basse température
la question du conditionnement du vaccin
pourrait être au coeur des
préoccupations logistique pour un pays
comme l'allemagne pas de problème un des
leaders mondiaux du secteur qui se
trouvent se trouvent sur son territoire
chez nous quelques entreprises
produisent certains de ses congélateurs
mais des usines mais leur usine se situe
en roumanie sur et sur le gâteau
plusieurs pays européens ont passé
commande avant même que les temps de se
manifester
la france aurait dû anticiper pendant de
nombreuses années les gouvernements
successifs ont laissé partir nos
entreprises industrielles cette crise
nous amène à repenser notre modèle de
société
non pas en abondant dans la théorie de
l'argent magique mais en rapatriant
notre capacité de production nationale
et en particulier dans les secteurs les
plus stratégiques
en conclusion rappelons que le vaccin
n'est pas plus dangereux que l'épidémie
est que si la variole ou la tuberculose
ont disparu de nos sociétés c'est bien
grâce au vaccin
je vous remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres collègues
nous déplorons qu'une nouvelle fois le
parlement ne soit pas associé à la
définition de la stratégie à adopter
face à la pandémie que connaissent notre
pays et le monde depuis bientôt un an
certes le débat est toujours utile et
nécessaire mais celui que nous avons
aujourd'hui ne sera suivi d'aucun vote
d'aucune prise de décision qui
appartiendraient à la représentation
nationale depuis le début de la crise il
nous a été demandé de voter pour ou
contre la confiance envers votre
gouvernement mais jamais aucune des
propositions travail et par vaux
opposition n'a retenu votre attention
c'est le cas de mon groupe la france est
soumise qui depuis le début au mois de
mars vous aura proposé une quinzaine de
loi cinq plans dont un plan complet de
déconfinement quatre guides dont un
guide de protection des salariés et plus
récemment encore un plan d'alternative
au confinement non
le monarque décide de tout tout seul ou
dans le cadre d'un gouvernement
parallèle soumis au secret défense le
fameux conseil de défense bien sûr nous
savons qu'il n'est pas simple de prendre
des décisions face à une crise sanitaire
mais les errements multiples dans la
gestion de celle-ci et la perte de
confiance qui en résultent aurait lu
vous amener à changer de stratégie nous
savons que nous n'avons pas fini avec ce
virus et encore moins avec ses
conséquences économiques et sociales
or les français ont besoin de voir le
bout du tunnel
le vaccin suscite beaucoup d'espoirs
dans la perspective d'en finir avec la
coved 19 mai la stratégie vaccinale doit
être transparente elle doit s'adapter
aux incertitudes et se combiner à une
stratégie thérapeutiques et préventives
la moitié des français ne veut pas se
faire vacciner et il n'est pas vrai que
la moitié des français seraient par
principe anti vaccins ou succomberait à
des thèses complotistes
les doutes sont réels les inquiétudes
existent ils doivent être levés
tout est allé très vite comparativement
à la temporalité habituelle de mise sur
le marché d'un vaccin
on peut s'en féliciter les technologies
employées sont différentes d'un vaccin à
l'autre une technologie nouvelle
arn messagers va être employée aussi les
données à notre disposition sont encore
très partiels la haute autorité de santé
reconnaît que les recommandations
vaccinales seront amenés à évoluer à
mesure que de nouvelles données seront
disponibles
l'efficacité des vaccins la durée
d'immunité qui n'est pas encore établi
les caractéristiques de la maladie la
sécurité des vaccins
il s'agit là de la transparence
sanitaire qui contribuerait à lever
nombre d'interrogations légitimes
ensuite la transparence économique nous
intéresse la structure des coûts et le
prix le lieu de production
le régime de propriété intellectuelle le
régime de responsabilité car le secret
des affaires est un obstacle à cette
transparence
ainsi pour le moment nous avons
davantage vu les effets de certaines
annonces s'agissant des vaccins sur les
cours de bourse de bourse que nous
n'avons obtenu de détail s'agissant des
contrats passés la pandémie et mondial
le vaccin devrait donc être un bien
commun de l'humanité tout entière
or on sait que d'ores et déjà les pays
les plus riches qui représentent 15% de
la population mondiale ont fait main
basse sur 80% des stocks promis vacciner
toute la population mondiale coûterait
moins de 1% de ce que va coûter la
pandémie à l'économie mondiale je les
dis monsieur le premier ministre la
stratégie vaccinale doit se combiner à
une stratégie de thérapeutiques et
préventives
je m'étonne de si peu vous entendre
parler de la perspective d'un traitement
contre la copie de 19 à lille l'institut
pasteur est en train de mettre au point
un médicament dont les résultats sont
attendus en mai prochain
je renouvelle à cette tribune notre
proposition de création d'un pôle public
du médicament en france pour mettre le
médicament au service de l'intérêt
général
en intégrant la recherche fondamentale
et la production des molécules
indispensable il n'est pas supportable
que 80% de nos médicaments soit importé
il faut produire en france
de même il faut mettre un terme immédiat
aux fermetures de lits à l'hôpital qui
se poursuivent en ce moment même enfin
en cas de troisième vague
il est urgent
de préparer les alternatives au
confinement renforcement des protocoles
sanitaires et organisations de roulement
dans tous les secteurs de la société où
cela est possible
déployons les grands moyens quoi qu'il
en coûte pour limiter au maximum la
circulation du virus tout en permettant
que la vie continue je résume vaccin aux
conditions que j'ai cités traitement
prévention protocole sanitaire et
alternative au confinement serait de
notre point de vue les ingrédients d'une
bonne stratégie pour en finir avec cette
pandémie
monsieur le premier ministre j'aime la
france sans ses salles de cinéma sans
ses théâtres
sans ces concerts sans ses bars et ses
restaurants ce n'est plus vraiment la
france l'assemblée nationale prend
parfois cela arrive des allures de grand
théâtre
et pourtant nous sommes ouverts merci de
et la parole sylvia pinel pour le
groupe liberté territoire pour dix
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
bientôt un an que notre pays et le monde
luttent contre un virus inconnu et
dévastateur un an vécu comme une
éternité par les professionnels de santé
sur mobilisés depuis la première heure
professionnels à qui je veux exprimer à
nouveau notre gratitude et notre
reconnaissance
si notre système de santé a tenu c'est
grâce aux soignants eux qui en faisant
leur devoir font plus que leur travail
une éternité aussi pour nous tous
bouleversés dans nos vies affectés par
une grave crise économique et des
restrictions de liberté importante et je
dois vous dire que ces dernières
semaines ont été particulièrement longue
pour moi qui comme tant d'autres aient
eu à lutter contre cette maladie
celle qui vous laisse dans un état de
grande épuisement et dont je dois vous
avouer n'être pas encore totalement
remises seco vide l'ont encore trop
méconnu et sous-estimé un an disait
c'est une éternité mais ces six cours à
l'échelle de la recherche scientifique
un effet un an après avoir découvert ce
virus après avoir séquencer son génome
après les trois phases d'essai clinique
voilà que nous débattons d'une stratégie
vaccinale et ce à seulement moins d'un
mois du début d'une campagne de
vaccination le calendrier s'est
accélérée à une vitesse presque
déconcertante avant le nul n'aurait pu
imaginer que les recherches et les
essais cliniques aboutir et si vite un
résultats même partiels
c'est peut-être ce qui explique que
cette contradiction propre à la france
nous qui nous risquions de grands
espoirs dans la découverte d'un vaccin
nous devenons très méfiants et très
hésitant quand celle ci survient
monsieur le premier ministre je connais
les difficultés de l'action publique
plus encore en cette période de grande
incertitude
ceci doit nous appeler nous responsables
politiques à la modestie et à la raison
pour autant la méfiance et les doutes
qui monte dans le pays ne doivent pas
être pris à la légère
elle pourrait causer l'échec de la
politique vaccinale ce que nous devons
c'est trouver un équilibre pour que
notre stratégie ne soit ni précipiter ni
tardive la sécurité de tous ne doit pas
être sacrifiée sur l'autel d'une
quelconque pression populaire encore
moins économique avec le vaccin
l'occasion nous est donnée de ne pas
reproduire les erreurs commises depuis
le début de la crise aussi notre groupe
estime que 3 impératives doivent être
réunies pour mener à bien cette
stratégie vaccinale
le premier consiste à délivrer une
information claire et transparente pour
construire la confiance avec les
citoyens
l'adhésion au projet vaccinale ne se
fera pas sans transparence
cela implique de dire ce que nous savons
mais aussi ce que nous ne savons pas en
l'occurrence nous regrettons que les
résultats des essais cliniques étaient
été repris dans des communiqués de
presse avant de faire l'objet d'articles
scientifiques
les laboratoires doivent publier leurs
résultats comme certains commencent à le
faire depuis peu et ce d'autant que ce
défaut de transparence traduit la
compétition économique à laquelle se
livrent les industriels ce qui n'est pas
de nature à rassurer compte tenu des
investissements publics importants dans
ce domaine nous sommes en droit d'exiger
des garanties solides
au-delà des résultats scientifiques la
transparence doit aussi se faire sur les
contrats de pré commande passée par la
commission européenne
nous connaissons les industriels
concernés et les sommes engagées
nous ne connaissons rien des conditions
d'achat les impacts pour les usagers ne
sont pourtant pas anodin quelle sera la
politique d'indemnisation en cas
d'effets indésirables par exemple il
serait judicieux d'éclaircir ces aspects
car l'opacité autour de ces contrats ne
peut que nourrir la défiance gens bien
justement aux patients aux citoyens nous
devons les impliquer le plus possible
car la démocratie sanitaire a été
largement mise de côté depuis le début
de la crise alors même que nous savons
que la moitié de la population française
n'envisage pas de se faire vacciner la
communication revêt un enjeu crucial
elle doit donc être la plus claire
possible la plus pédagogique sans
infantiliser les français je rejoins le
professeur le professeur alain fischer
lorsqu'il dit que nous avons besoin de
messages ciblés répété en évitant
surtout les arguments d'autorité et les
injonctions émanant des responsables
sanitaires
ce sont avant tout la communication
guerrière qui a prévalu jusqu'ici
valorisant l'esprit de responsabilité et
la cohésion sociale luttons avec plus de
force contre les fausses informations en
particulier celles relayées sur internet
et les réseaux sociaux
pour ce faire nous devons nous appuyer
sur l'heureux le réseau des
professionnels de santé de proximité
notamment les médecins traitants ces
derniers auront un rôle capital pour
rétablir la confiance et obtenir le
consentement éclairé des patients
cela nécessite que ces derniers soient
eux mêmes bien informée ce n'est pas le
cas pour l'instant cette information est
d'autant plus nécessaire que nous avons
encore beaucoup à apprendre de ce virus
et que les premiers vaccins sont issus
d'une technologie nouvelle dite de la rn
messager aujourd'hui il est évident que
nous manquons de recul sur un grand
nombre d'aspects liés au virus et aux
vaccins
raison pour laquelle nous voulons faire
preuve de précaution mais la précaution
n'empêche pas de faire preuve de
responsabilité de pragmatisme et donc de
nous organiser dès maintenant pour être
prêt voilà qui m'amène au deuxième
impératif qui consiste à prévoir une
logistique efficace aussi bien dans
l'urgence que dans la durée sur ce plan
aussi il faudra tirer les enseignements
des insuffisances passées sur les
masques sur les tests les questions sont
nombreuses
quelle garantie avons-nous concernant
les commandes
la france a commandé 200 millions de
doses au total mais selon quel
calendrier exact que sait-on des
processus de fabrication et de
production
rappelons nous de la grande dépendance
sanitaire dans laquelle nous nous sommes
trouvés il y a quelques mois
autre question où en sommes nous en
sommes nous des décisions en matière
d'acheminement et de distribution la
difficulté est renforcé par les
conditions de conservation et de
transport propres aux vaccins les plus
prometteurs ceux de pfizer bioritech et
modern à les conserver en moins 70
degrés les acheminer dans des délais
très courts n'est pas un sur
insurmontable mais c'est un défi
logistique qui requiert anticipation
méthodes aussi nous attendons du
gouvernement qu'il délivre des consignes
claires et fasse preuve d' écoute
certains hôpitaux ne comprennent pas
pourquoi ils devraient le faire office
de plateforme de stockage départementale
que leur répondez vous tous on
en mémoire la gestion des masques les
conclusions des rapports des commissions
d enquête notre assemblée du sénat sont
d'ailleurs édifiante
monsieur le premier ministre la campagne
de vaccination risque d'être longue
les vaccins arriveront vraisemblablement
au fur et à mesure de la production mais
aussi au fur et à mesure des
autorisations il ya fort à parier que
nous aurons à traiter non pas d'un
vaccin mais bien de plusieurs axes ans
avec à chaque fois des chaînes d'achat
mean man différentes
avez vous intégré cette difficulté
supplémentaire à votre stratégie
il faudra aussi se poser la question du
coût de ces vaccins alors même que les
vaccins les plus avancés sont aussi les
plus chers et que la vaccination sera
entièrement prise en charge par l'état
cela at il vocation à évoluer dans la
durée j'en viens au troisième impératif
celui d'une organisation territoriale de
proximité bien identifiés vous avez
souhaité que les médecins généralistes
soient au coeur du dispositif ce qui
nous paraît pertinent et même essentiel
cela suppose donc de les écouter ils
nous disent aujourd'hui qu'ils ne seront
probablement pas prêt pour un début de
phase de vaccination au coach janvier et
ce malgré l'accélération du calendrier
d'autorisation de l'agencé européenne du
médicament
nous craignons en effet un manque
d'anticipation au niveau territorial les
préfets les ars les médecins les
pharmaciens les infirmiers attendent le
mot d'ordre national afin de pouvoir le
décliner sur les territoires or ils
craignent de manquer de temps pour le
faire
nous devons dès maintenant identifier
les lieux de vaccination adapté pourquoi
ne pas s'appuyer sur les centres de
dépistage kovy dans lesquelles chacun
pourrait se rendre après prescription du
médecin généraliste
de la même manière les ehpad qui seront
les premiers concernés par la campagne
vaccinale ne seront pas prêts il faut
les accompagner et les soutenir pour
recenser les besoins recueillir les
consentements de manière éclairée et
sécurisé et s'organiser pour pouvoir
procéder aux vaccinations
s'agissant de la campagne à proprement
parler nous regrettons que les personnes
âgées à domicile ne soient pas concernés
par la première phase de vaccination
alors qu'elles sont aussi vulnérables et
potentiellement exposés en raison
notamment de nombreux intervenants à
domicile
par ailleurs si nous vous rejoignons sur
le choix d'une vaccination non
obligatoire
compte tenu du manque de recul sur de
nombreux points les médecins libéraux
alerte en revanche sur un point
important
comment comptez vous assurer leur
protection juridique envisagez vous d'en
faire des collaborateurs aux causes
occasionnels du service public
enfin nous insistons sur la nécessité du
suivi des personnes vaccinées à court
terme pour s'assurer que la vaccination
soit complète mais aussi pour prévenir
les effets secondaires
il faudra également un suivi de long
terme pour connaître la réelle
protection offerte par le vaccin
et pour faire des recommandations selon
les spécificités des populations pour
cela nous avons besoin d'un système
d'information adaptés plus performant
que le carnet de vaccination numériques
actuels qu'avez vous prévu comment
prévoyez-vous de renforcer le dispositif
de pharmacovigilance en la matière chers
collègues il est normal que nous
nourrissions de grands espoirs dans le
vaccin
la succession de confinement des
confinement n'est pas soutenable
elle pèse trop lourd sur nos concitoyens
sur notre économie sur notre santé mais
il est précipitée erroné de penser que
le vaccin suffira à vaincre l'épidémie
il nous faudra très probablement vivre
encore longtemps avec ce virus c'est
pour cela qu'il faut une stratégie
claire transparente la prévention avant
tout le dépistage ensuite finalement
monsieur le premier ministre si nous ne
devions retenir commandes ordre ce
serait le suivant anticipées de manière
concertée et transparente
trois dimensions qui ont souvent fait
défaut depuis le début de la crise mais
qui seront nous l'espérons demain au
rendez vous pour le vaccin
merci
la parole est à monsieur le président
andré chassaigne pour le groupe de la
gauche démocrate et républicaine pour
dix minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre madame et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues nous abordons
aujourd'hui un débat sur une question
cruciale pour l'avenir sanitaire
économique de notre pays
dix mois après la survenue de la
pandémie
l'arrivée d'un vaccin pour lutter contre
la copie 19 suscite beaucoup d'espoirs
chez nos concitoyens laissant entrevoir
une porte de sortie à cette crise qui
met à rude épreuve l'ensemble de notre
société
elle suscite également des
interrogations et des inquiétudes qui
interviennent dans un contexte de
défiance à l'égard du gouvernement qui
par ses amphigouri n'a pas su inspirer
la confiance auprès des français pour
gérer cette séquence sanitaires oubliant
pour reprendre eluard que les mots sont
des oiseaux sauvages qu'on ne rattrape
jamais quand ils sont lâchés le fiasco
des masques dont l'usagé était
conditionnel état des stocks a largement
contribué à décrédibiliser votre action
c'est le cas également de la stratégie
de test qui n'a pas pu prévenir une
seconde vague en raison d'une embolie du
système et de résultats donnés de
manière tardive
cette défiance est aussi le résultat
d'une gestion verticale voir
infantilisant de l'exécutif mettant de
côté les corps intermédiaires les locaux
comme le pouvoir législatif privilégiant
trop longtemps la puissance de feu d'un
croiseur par crainte de manger son
chapeau plus concertée la stratégie
vaccinale annoncé le 4 décembre par le
gouvernement marque une nouvelle étape
dans la lutte contre cette pandémie
si ces mesures vont dans le bon sens en
permettant une priorisation des des
publics tout en s'appuyant sur la
médecine de ville
des incertitudes demeurent sur la
déclinaison concrète opérationnelle des
campagnes de vaccination notamment sur
l'organisation du transport des vaccins
ou sur les lieux de vaccination qui
assurera le transport du vaccin
qu'en sera-t-il de l'accès aux vaccins
dans les déserts médicaux
nous attendons ce début de ce débat qui
puisse vous éclairer sur ces différentes
questions
la sensibilité politique que je reprenne
ante et culturellement historiquement
par son rapport à la science
défenseur de la vaccination non
seulement parce qu'elle permet à chacun
de se protéger d'un virus mais aussi
parce que c'est un acte collectif qui
vise à protéger des autres dans le but
d'atteindre une immunité de groupe
c'est pourquoi tout doit être fait pour
garantir un accès le plus large possible
aux vaccins dans la population une fois
que nous disposerons des validations de
la part des autorités sanitaires
compétentes au niveau européen et
national
nous souscrivons par ailleurs pleinement
à la gratuité du vaccin comme à son
caractère non obligatoire
ces conditions nous paraissait essentiel
pour lever les craintes t'exprimes
certains de nos concitoyens je n'ai
qu'une passion celle de la linière
disait moulins alors que l'adhésion à la
vaccination était largement partagée il
ya encore quelques années le niveau de
défiance est désormais l'un des plus
élevés d'europe davantage d'ailleurs que
dans la vaccination elle même les
explications sont à rechercher dans la
crise démocratique profonde qui touche
notre pays comme dans les dérives liées
à la financiarisation de l'industrie
pharmaceutique sur fond de
multiplication de scandales sanitaires
qui a crevé les yeux des hommes leur
reproche d'être aveugle dans la mise en
oeuvre de votre stratégie
la confiance sera donc primordiale mais
la confiance se décrète pas elle se
construit c'est la raison pour laquelle
tout là pour transparence doit être
faite sur la stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement et les modalités de
production et de distribution des
vaccins
cela suppose tout d'abord de faire la
lumière sur les contrats passés par
l'union européenne avec les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques sur les sommes d'argent
public versé sur le coût des vaccins sur
les garanties demandées aux industriels
alors que certains laboratoires comme
pts 6 heures ce niv déjà les marges
qu'il pourrait dégager
il apparaît impératif que tous les
vaccins soient commercialisés à prix
coûtant
il est inacceptable que cette pandémie
aliments de l'addiction à la poudre
blanche des profits cela suppose de
renforcer les moyens les outils publics
dédiés à la pharmacovigilance permettant
de disposer des connaissances sur les
effets secondaires des vaccins qui
pourrait apparaître dans la population
et m et de mettre en place les
procédures pour les éviter
cela suppose aussi de répondre à toutes
les inquiétudes même les plus petites
comme celle qui m'a été formulée cet
après-midi même sur un éventuel danger
de se faire vacciner en étant déjà
porteur du virus
il n'y a pas de petites inquiétudes cela
suppose également d'associer à chaque
fois que c'est possible les citoyens les
élus locaux et plus largement les
acteurs de la société civile à la
stratégie de vaccination aussi la mise
en place d'un collectif citoyen
parallèlement à la création d'un conseil
orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
va-t-elle dans le bon sens pour autant
nous sommes toujours interrogative quant
à sa composition et ses prérogatives
précise cela suppose enfin que le
parlement ne soit pas relégué au rôle de
spectateur c'est pourquoi nous vous
proposons de prendre date dès maintenant
monsieur le premier ministre afin qu'un
débat de la même nature ait lieu dans
cet hémicycle en mars prochain nous
aurons alors le recul nécessaire pour
évaluer les première phase de
vaccination chez les personnes âgées et
les personnes les plus fragiles face au
virus
outre la confiance démocratique notre
pays de retrouver sa pleine souveraineté
sanitaires économiques industrielles
chacun constate cette crise sanitaire a
passé notre pays au révélateur
elle a montré l'affaiblissement et la
relégation de la france dans des
domaines qui faisait auparavant sa force
conséquences des politiques néolibérales
et du dogme de la réduction des dépenses
publiques
notre modèle social a été abîmée comme
en témoigne la paupérisation d'hôpital
public la dégradation des conditions de
travail des personnels soignants la
pénurie de lits ou le manque
d'équipements de protection constaté
en plein milieu de la première vague des
constats largement relayée par les
rapports des deux commissions d enquête
parlementaire sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire
il faut aussi souligner
l'affaiblissement de notre modèle
industriel dans le secteur du médicament
malgré la présence de fleurons nos
outils de production industrielle font
désormais défaut sur le territoire
national les pénuries de médicaments et
d'équipements sont multipliés sous
l'effet de délocalisation dans les pays
à bas coûts la faute aussi à la
financiarisation du secteur
pharmaceutique qui exigent des taux de
rentabilité toujours plus indécent au
point au point qu'un groupe comme sanofi
se désengage de la production des
principes actifs les moins rentables en
créant une structure autonome en
négligeant notre souveraineté sanitaires
nous nous sommes placés dans une
situation de double dépendance
dépendance économique dépendances
sanitaires à l'égard des grandes firmes
pharmaceutiques
notre modèle de recherche publique enfin
qui faisait figure d'excellence a
souffert de l'insuffisance de
financement alors que nous disposons de
très grands chercheurs la recherche
publique
ainsi été délaissées sur la question des
virus respiratoires et des vaccins est
reine des domaines où nous étions
pourtant en pointe
nous aurions certainement pu anticiper
élaborer un vaccin avant que ne
survienne la pandémie au moyen de nos
organismes publics reconnus comme le
cnrs ou l'institut pasteur
tous ces constats appelle de nouvelles
orientations et des moyens publics
renforcer la santé comme les vaccins
sont des biens communs qui nous faut
placer en dehors des lois du marché le
gouvernement doit donc jouer pleinement
son rôle au plan international pour que
le vaccin contre la copie 19 soit
déclarée comme un bien public mondial
permettant l'ouverture des brevets et
son accès aux plus grands
ombre et notamment aux pays pauvres
c'est l'objectif de la campagne
initiative citoyenne européenne ece
lancée par le parti communiste français
et 13 autres partis européens pour un
vaccin accessible à tous face à
l'emprise des logiques privé la priorité
doit être de poursuivre une
réappropriation publique et citoyenne
des vaccins et des médicaments
depuis longtemps nous parlementaires
communistes portons l'idée d'un pôle
public de médicaments et de la recherche
qui serait le support à une maîtrise
publique de la production et de la
distribution de vaccins et de
médicaments
cette proposition que le premier
ministre doit être mise en débat pour
restaurer notre indépendance sanitaires
enfin la création d'un vaccin ne doit
pas nous exonérer d'une stratégie
sanitaire globale pour lutter contre le
risque pandémique
elle doit s'articuler sa stratégie
autour de plusieurs priorités le
renforcement massif dans le système
public de santé le développement d'une
politique de prévention et des moyens
publics
je dis bien public pour la recherche sur
les vaccins et les traitements merci
monsieur position seulement
la parole est à monsieur thomas meunier
pour le groupe la république en marché
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les présidents de
groupe
mes chers collègues enfin enfin nous
pouvons avoir ce débat à l'assemblée
nationale
jeudi enfin parce que nous attendions
tous l'arrivée d'un vaccin
un vaccin dont les résultats seraient
jugés efficaces et fiables
scientifiquement c'est chose faite
il est ils sont là aujourd'hui et grâce
à la mobilisation internationale et une
coopération renforcée de la communauté
scientifique européenne dit vaccin son
tour dernière phase de développement et
quatre sont actuellement à l'étude par
l' agence européenne du médicament
cette coopération européenne mérite
d'être souligné car c'est dans les
crises que nous nous réinventons le
mieux que nous nous réformons le mieux
cette pandémie a ainsi provoqué la mise
en place des premiers fondements de
l'europe de la santé il aura fallu une
pandémie mondiale pour qu'enfin nous
puissions commencer à la bâtir à tomber
d'accord sur l'importance d'une europe
de la santé ambitieuse sur ces sujets la
france a été moteur fer de lance vous en
avez été des acteurs forts messieurs les
ministres
nous ne pouvons qu en être fier quand
une crise est mondiale nous ne pouvons
répondre que collectivement et
construire une solution commune au delà
des frontières
les moyens mis en terme de financement
et de recherche pour lutter contre ce
virus virus qui était encore inconnu il
ya un an sont exceptionnel et inédit à
l'image de la crise que nous
travaillerons ton il explique la
rapidité du développement de ces vaccins
rapidité qui ne peut remettre en cause
la qualité des recherches scientifiques
menées pour trouver un vaccin efficace
et contrer la propagation du commis de
19 depuis le début de cette crise
beaucoup de contre-vérités ont circulé
sur les réseaux sociaux et parfois même
ont été diffusées sur c'est bon j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs reprises mais je tiens à le
réaffirmer ici nous devons faire
confiance à nos scientifiques faire
confiance à la science
nous sommes le pays de pasteur à chaque
nouveau vaccin
les mêmes craintes et doutes reviennent
mais les faits sont là
les vaccins sauvent des vies chaque jour
quand nous avons voté sur ses bancs en
décembre 2010 est le passage de 3 à 11
d'accent obligatoire pour les enfants
c'était pour sauver des vies ne
l'oublions pas douter sur le bien-fondé
de l'existence des vaccins ce n'est pas
posée le doute au bon endroit
la vaccination sauf des millions de vies
dans le monde
la variole a pu être éradiquée grâce aux
vaccins tétanos qui havre jaune
coqueluche rougeole oreillons sont
autant de maladies graves dont le
seulement et frais que nous parvenons
aujourd'hui à maîtriser grâce au vaccin
les vaccins sauvent des vies l'effet que
nous lé les bobards qu il est légitime
de nous interroger sur plusieurs aspects
des vaccins développés mais il s'agit de
doute est là où il faut nous interroger
sur la fabrication des vaccins leur
conservation leurs effets secondaires la
durée de l'immunité sur la manière dont
ils seront acheminés les étapes de leur
déploiement
autant de questions auxquelles la
stratégie vaccinale du gouvernement doit
répondre auxquels nous devrons répondre
car pour que la vaccination fonctionne
il faut que les français aient confiance
en celle ci c'est essentiel pour sauver
des vies il faut que les professionnels
de santé puissent disposer de toutes les
informations relatives à ces vaccins
pour rassurer leurs patients nous le
savons les français écoutent leur
médecin ils ont confiance en leur
médecin en leurs soignants si l'immunité
collective indispensable pour enfin
venir à bout de cette épidémie il passe
par la vaccination
j'en suis certain elle ne doit pas pour
autant se faire au détriment de la
sécurité sanitaire et la transparence
doit être le maître mot de notre
stratégie vaccinale une stratégie
vaccinale en plusieurs étapes et qui
comme nous l'avons fait depuis le début
de la crise devrait en appeler à la
responsabilité de chacun le président de
la république l'a ainsi annoncé aux
français lors le 24 novembre dernier la
vaccination ne sera pas obligatoire
chacun sera libre de se faire vacciner
ou non 200 millions de doses ont ainsi
déjà été commandés par notre pays afin
d'être en capacité de répondre au besoin
de chaque français
vous l'avez indiqué monsieur le premier
ministre lors de votre présentation de
la stratégie nationale de la vaccination
le 3 décembre dernier cette vaccination
sera gratuite
200 millions de doses gratuite car nous
devons obtenir cette immunité collective
quoi qu'il en coûte elle est
indispensable pour qu'enfin nous
puissions reprendre une vie normale pour
qu'enfin nous puissions serré à nouveau
nos proches contre nous al'approche des
fêtes de fin d'année ces vaccins sonne
comme un espoir une promesse d'une année
2021 libre après une année 2009 1 sous
cloche d'ici là nous devons encore tenir
tenir ensemble les gestes barrières et
les restrictions sanitaires canada
royaume uni ou encore états unis les
premières campagnes de vaccination sont
donc lancés nous nous apprêtons à notre
tour a démarré la nôtre pour qu'elle
fonctionne et que notre immunité
collective prennent notre campagne
vaccinale doit être irréprochable
fiabilité sécurité transparence
confiance et responsabilité doit doivent
être notre boussole ces prochains mois
je sais le groupe la république en
marche c'est que le gouvernement sera au
monde
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
général
la parole est un mais c'est jean pierre
door pour le groupe l'est républicain et
pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
compétent ou pas compétent monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
là où la vie en mur l'intelligence perce
un mur cette phrase est tout à fait
d'actualité
les épidémies qui ont bouleversé le
cours de l'histoire comme la peste
bubonique en 541 décrite par prokop
la dernière épidémie de peste qui
éclatent à marseille en 1720 ce fut la
dernière vague de la peste en france un
nouveau fléau la variole avec 5 à 6
millions de décès en france au xviiie
siècle
sa disparition doit être 1800
l'aboutissement de la vaccination
dixit le médecin anglais génère
aujourd'hui 21e siècle
nous sommes face au co vite 19 ans
quelques décennies on découvrit les
bactéries et les virus
on inventa les techniques de la
vaccination on jeta les bases de
l'immunologie vaccins à base de vie rue
de virus ou de bactéries à tenait aux
vaccins utilisant des bactéries et virus
inactivé ce furent les débats de la
révolution passe tauriel puis on doit à
charles mérieux le développement de
l'industrie du vaccin en france
au fil des années la vaccination est
devenu un acte médical populaire elle
doit s'appuyer avant tout sur
l'éducation de la population
la compréhension des maladies
infectieuses la connaissance des vaccins
et la conscience des enjeux de santé
individuel et sociaux constituent le
socle sur lequel les politiques
vaccinales réussissent alors que les
traitements antiviraux sont au point
mort on ne mise à raison sur les vaccins
aujourd'hui la course au vaccin est
accélérée grâce d'ailleurs à
l'innovation sur le génie génétique l
arn messagers ont choisi certaines
biotech internationale au détriment de
la france absente sur cette technologie
comme en témoignent malheureusement le
report du vaccin de sanofi
alors que les autorités britanniques et
américaines ont donné leur feu vert au
vaccin
faye their vieux ntech pourquoi l'
agence européenne de médicaments
tarde-t-elle a annoncé sa décision
pourquoi l' agence nationale de sécurité
du médicament et des produits de santé
n'utilise t elle pas son droit à
l'autorisation temporaire d'utilisation
la fameuse athée eu en france m la f10 à
américaine a fait savoir publiquement
l'efficacité et la sûreté du vaccin
à rl de pfizer de même que la grande
bretagne et le canada
notre bureaucratie d'état comprend tels
que nous traversons la crise la plus
grave depuis 80 années et que chaque
jour perdu ce sont des drames de plus en
jambes on monsieur le premier ministre
les lourdeurs administratives et soyons
dans l'action la france se prépare à
l'arrivée des vaccins et le nouveau
chantier qui s'ouvre devant nous
s'apparente aux travaux d'hercule
quelles sont les conditions d'une
campagne vaccinale réussi il vous faut
relever un défi de production à
l'échelle nationale un défi de
logistique en termes de transport de
stockage de conservation réfrigéré de
distribution dans tous les territoires
régions départements et communes et nous
n'avons plus
l'eprus chargée de répondre aux crises
sanitaires qui gérait tout les stocks
sur qui s'appuyer comme en 2010 un autre
défi et pas des moindres ou et qu' il ne
reculera le vaccin en 2 doses à trois
semaines d'intervalle vous savez combien
ont boudé le vaccin h1n1 et je me
souviens personnellement que seuls huit
et demi pour cent des français l'avaient
acceptée et malgré une campagne de
grande ampleur en 2009 on en faisait
trop paraît-il ce que l'on a retenu
c'est que pour être efficace il s'agit
d'un chantier complexe qu'il vous faut
résoudre après la bataille et les couacs
des masques puis celle des tests l'état
n'a plus le droit à l'erreur
comment allez-vous organiser la lutte
contre la défiance et le déni du risque
pour ne pas perdre la bataille de la
vaccination
en 2009 l'état avait ciblé 94%
deux millions de doses de h1n1 auprès de
quatre entreprises françaises pour
vacciner 47 millions de nos concitoyens
on a vu malheureusement le résultat en
france on craint plus le vaccin que la
maladie or vous avez prévu 200 millions
de doses soit pour vacciner 100 millions
de personnes pourquoi ces chiffres et
quel est le calendrier vous avez prévu
de saisir tous les professionnels de
santé
ils se souviennent de la campagne de
2009 mais quelle sera l'organisation des
cabinets de médecine de pharmacie des
infirmiers quelle sera la tarification
spécifique qui leur incombent
ce sont les questions qu'ils se posent
et ne tardez plus pour terminer parlons
de votre stratégie des publics
prioritaires combien de français
vaccinés en mars
et combien en juin en priorité il faut
protéger tous les professionnels soldats
de première ligne face à la pandémie
soignant de tout statut public et privé
en établissement comment libéral ce qui
correspond à environ un million quatre
cent mille personnes et dans le même
temps on envisage la vaste campagne de
vaccination des citoyens qui affirment
tout comme leurs affections de longue
durée donc de maladies chroniques qui
présentent des risques de comorbidité y
compris en milieu de perse des personnes
âgées en ehpad
prenons l'exemple mais c'est donc de
l'allemagne mais attention la faiblesse
des doses des stocks risquent 12 ont
porté très loin dans cette vaccination
en conclusion je vous dis monsieur
premiers chiffres nous voulons nous le
républicain la réussite de la
vaccination
merci monsieur d'or merci monsieur le
député la parole est un monsieur
philippe berta pour le modem et pour dix
minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues une année
une année déjà elle coronavirus sera
scop 2 quittait son autre normale la
chauve-souris de la forêt du loup bay
pour avec ou sans intermédiaire affecté
l'homme cela est très probablement suite
à la déforestation locale qui a rabattu
des animaux en proximité de la
population du rohan ne voulons pas que
cette chauve souris possède un système
immunitaire sans égal qui lui permet
d'abriter de 10 à 20 souches de corner
fige aux différentes
le signal est clair pour ceux qui
pouvaient en douter de la santé végétale
dépend la santé animale de la santé
animale notre propre santé dès lors une
course contre la montre est engagée par
les scientifiques course facilité dans
ces étapes initiales en effet la partie
le plus fondamental sur la nature du
virus sur son mode d'entrée dans nos
cellules par l'intermédiaire de la
protéine us s appelait aussi prothèses
du spike virale avait été décidée dès le
début des années 2000 suite aux deux
épidémies à coronavirus que l'on avait
un petit peu oublié le maire ce et le
strass les techniques de séquençage à
haut débit envie de permis d'en établir
la fiche d'identité et cela
simultanément aux quatre coins du globe
se sont alors quelques 250 recherche
vaccinale qui se sont déployés associant
toutes les stratégies possibles du virus
inactivé en passant par la protéine
virale comme antigènes la plateforme
virale avec gen ducobu d'intégrer ou
encore l'utilisation d'acides nucléiques
adn ou arn
si cette dernière technique a été encore
peu utilisée n'oublions pas qu'elle est
quand même le résultat de plus de 20 ans
des groupes de plus 22 dollars de plus
de vingt années de recherche il s'agit
peut-être plus particulièrement de les
rênes messager qui codent cette fameuse
protéine s du virus produite par
synthèse chimique enrobé lipides pour la
protéger la dégradation et permet de sap
meilleure pénétration dans nos cellules
balladur après traduction en protéines
est ce les anticorps protecteurs
correspondant notre corps ainsi
entraîner à identifier cette dernière
l'a bloquera détruire le virus il nous
protégera ainsi de l'infection et de la
pathologie c'est donner envie
le monde de la recherche fondamentale et
ont été développés par la suite par des
entreprises de biotechnologie celle
qu'on appelle les biotech qui ont
finalisé cette innovation de rupture
pour enfin s'associer avec de grands
groupes pharmaceutiques
seuls aptes à financer des essais
cliniques sur les dizaines de milliers
d'individus a assuré la bioproduction de
centaines de millions de doses
vaccinales et assurer la distribution
ces dernières étapes ont été réalisés en
collaboration étroite avec les
cliniciens avec les agences d'évaluation
pour attester de la rigueur des études
menées et des résultats obtenus
le tout mis en libre accès sur les
réseaux dès le début et publiés dans les
plus grandes revues scientifiques très
dernièrement
sachons aussi que les conditions de mise
sur le marché des vaccins sont
renforcées par rapport à celles des
autres médicaments la réglementation
européenne impose un contrôle qualité de
100 % des lots de vaccins avant leur
mise sur le marché les résultats de
l'essai clinique ont été décrits non pas
comme un succès mais comme un véritable
triomphe
la seule incertitude vient de la durée
de l'immunité ainsi acquises qui bien
sûr ne peut encore être attesté au delà
trois mois il nous reste aujourd'hui à
tirer profit de ce succès extraordinaire
en relevant le challenge logistique
derniers verrous pour reconquérir notre
liberté
ce sera aussi quand même l'occasion de
questionner notre filière santé dans
bien des aspects métaux nous
suffisamment de moyens dans notre
recherche en santé
l'organisation de cette dernière ne
doit-elle pas être repensée pour plus
d'efficience la collaboration public
privé ne doit elle pas être plus
encouragés n'est-il pas temps de penser
un fonds d'investissement capable
d'accompagner l'épreuve est dans leur
développement départ dont les biotech
dans leur développement en deux pays
plutôt que de voir partir le produit de
notre recherche à l'étranger par
incapacité de financement des essais
cliniques
notre industrie at elle suffisamment
intégré dans son fonctionnement les
fondamentaux de l'ue négation ouverte
nos structures d'évaluation sont elles
suffisamment performante des moyens mis
à disposition des comités de protection
à la personne jusqu'au délai
d'instruction du comité économique des
produits de santé
enfin l'émergence des termes tels pcr rt
pcr arn messagers virus recombinant
immunité cellulaire l'immunité humorale
l'immunité collective ou encore
anticorps neutralisants dans les
discours grand public nous montre aussi
l'urgence d'une politique de culture
scientifique et technologique ambitieuse
à destination notre population meilleur
moyen de tordre le cou aux inepties
populiste et complotistes dans certains
médias se font le relais
le retour à la normalité donc sera
clairement liée à notre capacité
vaccinale pour prévenir la pathologie et
limiter la propagation de l'infection
cette vaccination devra se faire dans la
cadre de la confiance et de la
transparence
le choix du professeur alain fischer
le choix d'un conseil d'orientation sur
la stratégie vaccinale ou encore le
suivi d'éventuels effets indésirables
publié chaque semaine par
l'intermédiaire de centres de
pharmacovigilance régionaux en seront le
gage la stratégie vaccinale explosé
aujourd'hui par monsieur le premier
ministre en assurera la mise en oeuvre
la priorisation des publics cibles et le
séquençage dans le temps de la campagne
vaccinale répondre aux trois objectifs
qu'ils se doivent aujourd'hui d'être les
nôtres réduire les formes graves et la
mortalité protéger nos soignants et
garantir la sécurité des vaccins
la stratégie annoncée est également
celle de l'accessibilité avec une
multiplicité de lieux de vaccination et
la gratuité pour tous une universalité
indispensable pour qu'en france chacun
et les mêmes chances face au virus
le même accès à une protection de sa
santé dans la droite ligne des principes
fondateurs de notre sécurité sociale
le vaccin ne sera pas obligatoire mais
il nous faudra nous tous être porteur
d'une grande pédagogie
il nous faudra faire en sorte que se
mette en place une communication des
plus horizontale associant tous les
acteurs de la santé et ceux ci le plus
possible le plus tôt possible dans
l'autre tant il nous faudra également
maintenir nos efforts resté constant
dans les gestes barrières et la
limitation des contacts sociaux y
compris bien sûr pendant ces fêtes de
fin d'année nous avons des vaccins
nous avons une stratégie vaccinale nous
voyons enfin la lumière au bout du
tunnel
il ne faut à présent jeter nos dernières
forces dans la bataille contre le virus
jusqu'à ce que la vaccination du plus
grand nombre nous permettent de
reprendre le cours de la vie que nous
voulons je veux terminer en témoignant
ici toute mon admiration aux milliers de
chercheurs aux milliers d'ingénieurs au
millier de techniciens académique ou
privés dans le monde entier qui grâce à
un travail acharné jour et nuit sept
jours sur sept nous offre aujourd'hui
l'espoir dans un délai incroyable
bravo scientifiques bien sûr pour avoir
partagé leurs données mais aussi bravo
aux planificateurs des essais cliniques
bravo aussi aux dizaines de milliers de
volontaires et bravo aux autorités
gordon gouvernementale pour avoir su
trouver la souplesse nécessaire c'est la
promesse de pouvoir sauver un nombre
considérable de vie et de nous donner
enfin un chemin de sortie de ce désastre
mondial
à nous de savoir transformer cet espoir
désormais par une attitude responsable
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur olivier bêche pour le groupe a
joué ensemble et pour faire minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
collègues nous sommes réunis ici ce soir
pour débattre de la stratégie sanitaire
et plus particulièrement de la stratégie
vaccinale le vaccin chers collègues est
évidemment un espoir important
après une année 2009 qui a été
entièrement sinistrés par l'aco vite 19
ont néanmoins nous le savons tous la
stratégie vaccinale le succès de la
stratégie vaccinale repose sur cinq
conditions la première
bien entendu c'est que il y est à peu
près 60% des français qu'ils puissent se
vacciner et nous les invitons bien sûr à
le faire la deuxième c'est que le vaccin
et des effets durables efficace plus que
quelques mois la troisième c'est
évidemment que ce vaccin protège non
seulement le malade mais également la
transmission d'une personne qu'ils
soient affectés vers une autre personne
la quatrième c'est évidemment qu'il n'y
ait pas d'effets secondaires graves sur
cela que ça et là 5e c'est que le virus
ne lutte pas en cours de route
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
pensons que le vaccin est un espoir mais
qui ne doit pas être le seul espoir et
la stratégie populaire recommande
généralement de ne pas mettre tous ses
oeufs dans le même panier
et ce d'autant que nous le savons nous
le savons les effets du vaccin sur la
population ne pourront dans notre pays
produire véritablement tous leurs effets
que vers le deuxième semestre de l'année
2021 voir à la fin de l'année 2021 nous
avons donc encore plusieurs mois à vivre
avec le virus avant que le vaccin puisse
être un espoir effectifs dans la vie de
nos concitoyens
c'est la raison pour laquelle le groupe
agir ensemble a proposé au gouvernement
une stratégie qui repose elle aussi sur
un triptyque qui est d'abord de tester
massivement et parfois systématiquement
là où le virus circule le plus nous
savons aujourd'hui
le repérer notamment dans les eaux usées
donc nous pouvons concentrer les tests
pcr et antigénique là où le virus
circule le plus quand je dis
systématique
je n'exclus pas que l'on puisse rendre
ce dépistage obligatoire nous avons dans
notre droit de la santé publique
plus d'une trentaine d'examens médicaux
qui sont obligatoires et certains
beaucoup plus évasif qu'un simple coton
tige dans le nez il faut donc que se
donner les moyens de dépister le virus
chaque fois qu'il en est possible
ensuite accompagner les personnes qui
sont positives et les cas contacts de
manière digne et humaine
bien entendu pour leur permettre d'avoir
tout ce qu'il faut pour s'isoler faire
leurs courses à portée de l'alimentation
apporter des médicaments s'occuper des
enfants s'il le faut et puis bien sûr il
faut contrôler il faut contrôler cet
isolement il est absurde
mes chers collègues il est absurde dans
notre pays que l'on risque 135 euros
en sortant de chez soi sans attestation
pour aller promener son chien
mais quand l'on ne risque rien si on a
une attestation pour sortir avec la
queue vide 19 au risque de contaminer
d'autres personnes qui risquent de se
retrouver ensuite à l'hôpital en
réanimation voire pour certaines au
cimetière donc oui nous faisons
confiance à nos concitoyens mais nous le
savons et nous l'avons vu la semaine
dernière encore 500 personnes qui
faisait la fête en dehors de tout
respect du confinement et des gestes
barrières
il y aura dans notre société toujours et
encore des personnes qui ne respecteront
pas les règles c'est la raison pour
laquelle les personnes qui sont
positives doivent évidemment s'isoler et
une nécessaire de devoir les contrôler
et de sanctionner les personnes qui
s'exposeraient au risque de contaminer
d'autres de leurs concitoyens voilà si
vous voulez monsieur 1er mai chers
collègues la stratégie que nous
proposons d'employés elle nous semble
être au moment où l'année 2021
va démarrer la seule possible je dis
bien la seule possible jusqu'à ce que le
vaccin produise ses effets nous
implorons la représentation nationale et
le gouvernement de la suivre car nous
savons aujourd'hui qu'un troisième
confinement ne serait pas possible dans
notre pays n'est pas tenable ni
psychologiquement ni économiquement ni
financièrement
il nous faut donc à côté du vaccin
évolué sur la stratégie sanitaire des
pistes et massivement isolé en
accompagnant les personnes vulnérables
et évidemment contrôler ce confinement
des personnes positives de manière plus
stricte
monsieur le premier ministre mes chers
collègues je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci monsieur le président
la parole est à monsieur jean hugues
ratenon pour le groupe la france a
soumises et pour cinq minutes
c'est le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues en
préambule j'aimerais vous dire que je ne
suis pas médecin ni un spécialiste
encore moins sp en vaccins je me
garderais bien d'affirmer des choses
avec trop de certitudes sur un sujet
aussi sensible qui concerne la santé des
gens comme beaucoup j'écoute je lis
j'analyse les différents avis pour me
faire une opinion cela ceci m'amène à me
poser un certain nombre de questions et
en tant que parlementaire d'interroger
le gouvernement en juin 2018 la haute
autorité de santé a élaboré une fiche
détaillant les pré requis nécessaires à
l'élaboration de recommandations
vaccinales comme bien comprendre la
maladie infectieuse et ses
caractéristiques épidémiologiques avoir
des preuves suffisantes de l'efficacité
du vaccin et de sa tolérance notamment
sur la réponse immunitaire mesurer suite
à la vaccination
ces données sont généralement tenues
lors du développement clinique du vaccin
et conduisant suite à l'obtention d'une
autorisation de mise sur le marché
établi sur le rapport bénéfice risque du
vaccin et qui définit les indications et
les contre indications
avons-nous ces garanties où en
sommes-nous monsieur le ministre on
apprend que l'agencé européenne du
médicament a déjà commandé plusieurs
millions de doses mais ce réunion
réunira avant fin décembre pour statuer
sur une autorisation de mise sur le
marché européenne pour quel montant est
ce nécessaire de posséder dans cet ordre
y at il des garanties de prévue au cas
où l'autorisation ne serait pas accordée
pouvez-vous nous garantir la
transparence sur la fabrication et le
coût du vaccin
les experts nous disent aussi que pour
être conservés efficace qu'un des
vaccins doit être stocké au moins
soixante dix voire moins 80 degrés
celsius quelles garanties pouvez vous
nous apportez sur ce défi technique
le président de la république a répété
que le vaccin ne sera pas obligatoire
c'est une bonne chose mais en même temps
il serait en train de se mettre en place
un passeport sanitaire qu'il faudra
présenté à l'embarquement de tous les
avions dont les compagnies font partie
de l'état c'est à dire 80 % du trafic
mondial
pouvez vous nous donner l'assurance
qu'il ne sera pas obligatoire de se
faire vacciner pour accéder à certains
services vient maintenant la question de
la stratégie comme l'indiquent
l'intitulé de notre débat mais pas
seulement vaccinale fin novembre une
déclaration du professeur anneaux
fontanes et épidémiologiste membre du
conseil scientifique sur laquelle
s'appuie le président de la république
pour prendre ses décisions m'a
interpellé
le vaccin ne sera pas efficace à 100
poisson vacciner vous n'avez pas la
garantie de ne tomber malade vacciner je
peux encore transmettre le virus de
vaccins vont entraîner des effets
indésirables et vous savez que la
méfiance est importante dans une grande
partie de la population votre gestion de
l'épidémie n'a pas concouru à instaurer
une relation de confiance avec les
citoyens les contradictions sur le port
ou non du mak son efficacité le fiasco
des textes et cetera et cetera j'ai la
conviction que la clé pour obtenir la
confiance de nos concitoyens d'assurer
la transparence sur ces questions
tout ce qui concerne les vaccins contre
la copie 19 doit être décidée en
fonction uniquement de l'intérêt général
et non des intérêts privés de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
trop souvent les coûts notamment de
recherche sont assurés par le secteur
public mais les profits les brevets sont
récoltées par les entreprises privées
pourquoi ne faisons-nous plus appel à
l'institut pasteur roland donnant les
moyens afin d'apprivoiser de maîtriser
et d'éliminer le virus nous l'avons déjà
évoqué à plusieurs reprises un
médicament en cours d'études à
l'institut pasteur de lille dont les
résultats définitifs sont prévues pour
mai 2021 il faut parler franchement aux
français le vaccin est un outil de lutte
contre la copie 19 mais ce n'est pas
nécessairement la solution miracle il
faut en parallèle travailler sur des
solutions thérapeutiques pour traiter
les personnes malades conserver des
mesures préventives pour éviter de
multiplier les contaminations et
réfléchir à des alternatives au
confinement
comme nous l'avons fait en proposant un
pour un plan complet en novembre
en conclusion nous le réaffirmons ici
la france ne veut pas se passer d'un
pôle public du médicament ça a été dit
par plusieurs collègues et plus
largement des produits de santé ou dans
une moindre mesure de réinvestir
massivement dans la recherche publique
en la matière la confiance ne se décrète
pas elle se mérite
je vous remercie monsieur le député et
la parole est à madame fadila khattabi
pour la république en mars et pour cinq
minutes madame la présidente
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues le
monde entier affronte maintenant depuis
plusieurs mois une crise sanitaire sans
précédent face à ce virus inconnu nous
avons dû nous adapter et trouver les
solutions d'urgence des solutions
d'urgence sanitaire mais également
économique
je tiens en premier lieu à adresser mes
plus sincères remerciements à tous les
professionnels de santé qui depuis le
début de l'épidémie se sont fortement
mobilisés afin de soigner les malades
atteints de lakovic 19 les mois que nous
venons de traverser ont été éprouvants
et ce d'autant plus que le virus qui a
fait des centaines de milliers de morts
de part le monde est un ennemi invisible
cependant la souffrance de nos
concitoyens est bien réelle après un
premier confinement qui fut difficile le
deuxième confinement bien qu absolument
nécessaire a été vécu encore plus
douloureusement par les français qui ont
su toutefois faire preuve d'abnégation
et de résilience
cependant aujourd'hui n'est-il pas venu
le temps de l'espoir mes chers collègues
un vaccin est enfin notre portée il est
à la fois un exploit scientifique et un
espoir l'espoir d'une vie meilleure il
doit en effet nous permettre de
retrouver une vie normale
cette vie qui nous manque tant à toutes
et tous une vie faite de tendresse
d'étreintes de liberté la liberté de se
mouvoir de voyager de se cultiver
d'entreprendre
bref de vivre aussi mes chers collègues
cet après midi nous sommes réunis pour
débattre ensemble de la stratégie qui
sera la nôtre et grâce à laquelle nous
combattrons enfin cette épidémie ce
débat est indispensable non seulement
pour des raisons démocratiques mais
aussi parce qu'il répond à la principale
attente des français
une atteinte une attente pardon tout à
fait légitimes à savoir celle de la
transparence pour être digne de la
confiance des français il nous faut
faire preuve de transparence
d'ailleurs il ne suffit pas de dire la
vérité il faut encore la proclamer
déclaré pasteur l'inventeur de la
vaccination
il avait conscience de l'importance
ultime d'expliquer et de démontrer
l'utilité collective du vaccin
aussi je souhaite insister sur le rôle
qui sera le nôtre dans les prochains
mois et en premier lieu celui de la
commission des affaires sociales qui a
pleine compétence poursuivre le
déploiement de notre politique de
vaccination
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
décidé de saisir l'office parlementaire
des choix scientifiques et
technologiques sur la question de notre
stratégie vaccinale
une démarche qui permettra aux
parlementaires d'être éclairé sur les
enjeux scientifiques complexes de la
vaccination
l'office a d'ailleurs rendu hier ses
premières conclusions encourageantes
mais surtout éclairante sur les
conditions de réussite de notre
stratégie
l'adhésion au vaccin est fondamental
pour ce faire elle doit notamment
s'appuyer sur une bonne coordination des
acteurs dans les territoires en
associant la médecine de ville et
collectivités territoriales nous aurons
également l'occasion d'auditionner les
autorités scientifiques indépendantes
chargées de valider les autorisations de
mise sur le marché
monsieur le premier ministre trois
étapes jalonneront le parcours de
vaccination que le gouvernement
s'apprête à mettre en oeuvre trois
étapes au cours desquelles la commission
des affaires sociales initiera des
échanges constructifs avec vous toujours
dans un souci de transparence avec un
seul but informer et rassurer nos
concitoyens
vous avez également annoncé la création
d'un conseil d'orientation de la
stratégie vaccinale qui sera chargé
d'appuyer le gouvernement dans le choix
dans les choix à faire et qui comptera
notamment des citoyens nous ne pouvons
que nous réjouir de cette démarche
enfin en tant que parlementaire notre
action sera également sur le terrain à
la rencontre des soignants à la
rencontre de la population
depuis le début de l'épidémie nous avons
été deux nombres nombreux sur ses bancs
à visiter les hôpitaux mais également
les ehpad
nous devons encore aujourd'hui rester à
l'écouté du terrain et suivre le
déploiement des premières étapes de la
vaccination dans nos territoires
monsieur le premier ministre vous
l'aurez compris notre jeu notre objectif
est commun garantir la santé de nos
concitoyens et ce dans la plus grande
transparence
nous savons monsieur le premier ministre
pouvoir compter sur votre engagement et
sur votre souci d'informer la
représentation nationale au fil des
différentes étapes du déploiement de
notre stratégie vaccinale
nous marchons ensemble et c'est ensemble
que nous parviendrons à franchir les
derniers mètres de ce chemin qui nous
paraît sans fin car in fine et monsieur
le premier ministre
mes chers collègues seule compte la vie
toute la vie rien que la vie je vous
remercie
merci madame la présidente la parole est
à monsieur bernard perrut pour le groupe
l'est républicain et pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres
chers collègues la crise sanitaire
économique et social engendré beaucoup
de souffrance d inquiétude et
incompréhension voire même des
oppositions aux mesures prises par le
gouvernement et la méfiance est forte
chez beaucoup de français le 25 une
solution pour nous protéger du virus
assurer la sécurité des plus fragiles et
en finir avec les confinements
successifs mais encore faut-il que les
français retrouvent la confiance
comment il faut faire de la transparence
une priorité
transparent sur le processus
d'élaboration du 25 laboratoires ainsi
que sur sa fiabilité est lancé dès
maintenant grande campagne de
sensibilisation pour améliorer son
acceptabilité cette transparence est
indispensable pour préparer des français
on fixe un cap clair et les objectifs à
atteindre
alors où la défiance vis-à-vis du 25
devenue importante
53% des français seulement veulent se
faire vacciner
il est indispensable qu'une véritable
éthique de l'assignation soit mise en
place
la vaccination est un acte médical comme
les autres et retient une information
éclairée préalable sur la balance
risques bénéfices et un consentement
il faut associer le plus en amont
possible les acteurs de la santé oms
nature notamment les professionnels de
santé libéraux médecins généralistes au
plus près du terrain
infirmière libérale pharmaciens ces
professionnels de santé ont la confiance
et français car ils sont à leurs côtés
au quotidien monsieur le premier
ministre kan sera d'ailleurs produit ce
guide de vaccination pour tous les
professionnels de santé
ils attendent il sera bien sûr le
bienvenu il faut permettre à chaque
français de réaliser un test au sirop
logique avant de se faire vacciner afin
qu'il sache s'il détient des anticorps
par le biais de l'immunité collective ou
d'une éventuelle contamination passé
inaperçu en l'absence de symptômes
en france plus de 2 millions de
personnes ont déjà des contaminés par
l'aco vite 19 il faut éviter une
approche territoriale
monsieur premier ministre madame la
ministre il serait déconnectée des
français
qui consisterait à créer d'immenses
centres de vaccination éloignés de là où
ils vivent
mais son contraire prendre pour base les
structures de santé habituels en les
adaptant et en leur donnant des moyens
complémentaires avec le soutien des
collectivités territoriales très
investis pendant cette crise et
d'oublier pas d'ailleurs monsieur
communiste madame messieurs les
ministres les députés qui sont sur le
terrain est très impliqué d'ailleurs
pendant cette crise sanitaire
comment envisagez vous monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur madame
monsieur le ministre
lancement le même jour dans 27 pays de
la campagne de vaccination
il faut en tout cas mes chers collègues
que nous puissions adopté une
communication claire une transparence
totale sur les stocks disponibles sur
les publics prioritaires mais aussi sur
le taux d'efficacité du 25 et enfin les
potentiels effets indésirables afin de
dissiper toutes les polémiques
face à la défiance la seule bonne
réponse est d'expliquer et de rassurer
le risque d'effets secondaires bénin du
fréquentent habituellement pour
absolument être bien expliquer aux
personnes recevant le vaccin on risque
qu'une partie d'entre eux ne reçoivent
pas la seconde injection
dans ce cadre comment seront organisées
les consultations médicales près
vaccinale nos médecins pourront-ils
faire face à toutes ces consultations
la haute autorité de santé mattel
émettre des recommandations quant aux
incompatibilités pour certains passion
ou résidant selon leur état de santé
il est indispensable de mettre en place
une politique extrêmement volontariste
pour vacciner dans un premier temps en
grande majorité des personnes à risques
et le personnel soignant vous ne l'avez
indiqué je pense bien sûr aux personnes
âgées dépendantes en ehpad
je pense au soignant à l'hôpital en
ville ou en établissements de santé et
médico-sociaux et enfin aux personnes
présentant une comorbidité et qui sont
susceptibles d'avoir des formes plus
grand du virus en cas de contamination
pour ces groupes à risque l'arrêt doit
être la vaccination et la non
vaccination
seulement les déceptions mais des
questions demeurent encore d'être
urgemment tranché à quelle date et
combien de 25 les établissements vont
ils recevoir
je pense à nos hôpitaux désignés dans
chaque département
et qui doivent affecter les dozos
différents établissements quelle chaîne
logistique pour transporter stocker
réfrigérée distribuer les vaccins en
respectant les conditions de
conservation et des rentes à chacun
comment accompagner notamment les ehpad
pour un déploiement rapide de la
vaccination
comment se fera le suivi la surveillance
à court et à long terme par les
effecteurs eux mêmes par le schéma
classique de la pharmacovigilance par
des études pharmaco épidémiologiques par
des suivis de kort de population et
enfin quand le 25 at il vraiment un rôle
puisque le président du conseil
scientifique estime que l'arrivée des 25
contre lakovic 19 ne modifiera le cours
de l'épidémie en france qu'à partir de
l'été 2021
quelle mesure entendez-vous prendre
d'ici là monsieur le premier ministre
pour faire face à d'éventuels troisième
vague dès février sur l'ensemble de ces
sujets nous attendons vos
éclaircissements
car cette bataille là nous ne pouvons
pas la perdre
nous devons la gagner tous ensemble tout
repose sur la décision individuelle ne
se faire vacciner et dont des libertés
de chacun et c'est parce que je n'oublie
pas ce que l'humanité doit au vaccin
pour ma part monsieur le premier
ministre je me ferai vacciner dès que
cela sera possible à vos côtés au côté
du ministre de la santé et on côté
madame la ministre déléguée
je vous remercie merci monsieur période
même si je sens que je sors de mort de
ma réserve je veux bien vous accompagnez
me supérieur donc vous à toutes les
sensibilités seront représentés monsieur
hubert julien laferrière pour les non
inscrits et pour cinq minutes sur le
président sur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues alors que l'europe est
durement frappée par fait deuxième vague
ce qui se joue au coeur de la stratégie
vaccinale
c'est tout simplement l'espoir l'espoir
pour les français de retrouver une vie
sociale une vie normale retrouvez son
travail pour beaucoup trouver du travail
aller au théâtre
au concert au cinéma l'espoir pour les
artistes les créateurs les hauteurs de
retrouver les planches pour susciter nos
émotions
l'espoir pour les commerçants les
restaurateurs les cafetiers les lieux de
nuit pour nous redonner la joie l'espoir
pour les bénéficiaires du plan de
relance dont avec certains nous avons
pointé la suffisance redistributive mais
qui ne pourra en tout cas pas se
déployer
s'il n'ya pas le retour de la confiance
et il n'y aura pas de confiance des
acteurs économiques sans confiance
sanitaire au mois de juin nous
célébrions le retour des jours heureux
alors qu'un mois auparavant les
scientifiques avaient alerté sur la
deuxième vague et ce matin même
l'om est confirmée le risque très élevé
d'une troisième vague
demain les jours heureux ce sont aux
scientifiques que nous les devront car
nous avons déjà à faire cela était bien
sûr rappelé par vous-même surprise par
vous monsieur me de la santé nous avons
affaire à un exploit scientifique tant
du fait des délais exceptionnel qu'avec
cette avancée extraordinaire qui est la
technologie de la rn messager n'en
déplaise aux vaccinaux sceptiques
n'en déplaise aux scientifiques aux
sceptiques je sais le terme n'existe pas
mais au rythme où ça va il pourrait être
bientôt validé par l'académie française
n'en déplaise à ces sujets de l'effet de
dunes in trees guerre ce biais cognitifs
qui porte le nom de ses deux
psychologues qui ont montré que moins on
en sait plus on croit savoir et c'est un
phénomène vous le savez qui est exacerbé
par les réseaux sociaux je ne dis pas
qu'il faut pas débattre bien sûr ce
départ le parlementaire est important et
j'en profite pour saluer les travaux de
nombreux collègues et en particulier les
travaux de l'opecst tu présidée par
notre collègue ville ali c'est un débat
auquel il faut associer les français
nous devons débattre
nous devons même douter ce n'est pas le
doute qui rend fou c'est la certitude
nous rappeler nietzsche essais mais le
même le doute qui fait avancer la
science mais du doute ne doit pas naître
la défiance envers elle et c'est là que
se situe la ligne de crête
alors rappelons encore une fois que la
vaccination a permis d' éradiquer la
variole la polio à 99%
fait baissé de 80% les décès de la
rougeole rappelons qu'elle permet chaque
année de sauver de la mort
trois millions de personnes qui sont
exposées à la diphtérie tétanos la
rougeole à la coqueluche une seule chose
mais faire collègues il ya eu autant
d'impact sur la mortalité dans
l'histoire de la minute d'humanité c'est
l'assainissement des eaux
le vaccin protège pour le premier en
tout cas contre les formes graves mais
c'est vrai on ne sait pas quelle est la
durée de la production on n'est pas sûr
qu'ils empêchent la transmission et
alain fischer le rappelait ce matin sur
une grande radio nationale nous aurons
donc certes besoin de plus de recul mais
regardons ce que le vaccin apporte la
protection des plus fragiles et la
perspective d'une immunité collective il
nous faut donc convaincre convaincre les
français qu'ils ne comprennent pas
toujours les décisions prises ces
dernières semaines car ce défi sanitaire
est aussi un défi démocratique si
essentiel dans notre stratégie vaccinale
gratuite et universalité couverture de
l'ensemble du territoire qui exige une
organisation logistique si complexe et
et je veux ici saluer les services de
l'état en particulier service de votre
ministère monsieur mise la santé et puis
parce que cette question logistique
elle n'est évidemment pas négligeable
mais vous l'avez rappelé
et puis à associer les français en zone
3 de transparence surtout quand on a
choisi à juste titre une stratégie qui
repose sur l'absence d'injonction et
libre choix en commençant bien sûr par
les problèmes par les professionnels de
santé qui sont par leur relation de
proximité les mieux placés pour
convaincre et qui auront besoin d'être
encore davantage soutenu vacciner c'est
un peut recevoir en consultation
enfin parce que les virus voyage sans
passeport sans visa nous avons besoin
d'une solidarité mondiale pour que bien
public mondial ne soit pas qu'un seul
slogan nous avons besoin d'une
coordination européenne qui a fait
défaut lors de la première vague mais
qui est cette fois au rendez vous il a
désormais une vraie diplomation
européennes y compris dans la
surveillance du virus cette veille
virologique strictes pour le
ou lever resteraient amis a muté encore
plus qu'il ne l'a fait au royaume uni
l'europe doit donc développé ses propres
outils scientifiques c'est une question
d'efficacité dans la lutte contre le
virus
c'est aussi bien sûr une question de
souveraineté européenne pour l'avenir je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole et à
madame marie le bec pour la république
en marche et bon cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
chers collègues la stratégie vaccinale
soulisse par le gouvernement est une
nouvelle étape dans la guerre que nous
menons depuis près d'un an contre le
virus
les prochaines étapes seront décisives
et les défis que nous aurons à relever
collectivement immense la france la
prépare depuis des mois dans les
domaines scientifique et industrielle
grâce à la mobilisation des chercheurs
des laboratoires des organismes de
recherche publics et privés et des
milliers de volontaires en france et à
l'international
rarement l'intelligence collective et le
génie scientifique internationale
n'auront autant été mobilisés dans un
but commun développer un vaccin efficace
fiable capable de sauver des vies
au-delà de cet engagement international
il s'agit aussi de garantir la
production et l'accès de la france a un
nombre de suffisant de vaccins
le président de la république en a fait
dès le début une priorité avec
l'objectif que le vaccin soit un bien
public mondial
disponible accessible et abordable pour
toutes les nations grâce à la coalition
initiée dans le cadre du g20
ce combat a porté par la france a été
soutenue et partager nous pouvons en
être fiers
au plan européen la france s'est battue
pour une réponse concertée et collective
comme nos concitoyens comment nos
concitoyens aurait-il pu tolérer une
compétition entre états membres alors
même que nous déplorons plus de 300000
morts en europe
aussi pour garantir une répartition
proportionnelle des vaccins entre les
états et un prix juste
nous avons pris l'initiative avec
l'allemagne l'italie les pays-bas de
créer une task force
s'appuyant sur la commission européenne
en charge de négocier et de contracter
avec les laboratoires
je tiens ici à saluer le travail mené
par les ministres en espagne r une
hache-- et clément boon qui a été
déterminant pour faire aboutir la
stratégie européenne
les résultats sont là si contrat de
préachat européens ont été signés deux
nouveaux sont en négociation une clé de
répartition a pu être établi et la
france bénéficiera de près de 200
millions de doses garantissant une
couverture vaccinale maximale nous
attendons désormais que le que les
autorisations de l'agencé européenne du
médicament
c'est à ce prix que nous pourrons
garantir à nos concitoyens la qualité et
la sûreté du vaccin
l'efficacité de cette stratégie passera
également par la sécurisation de
l'approvisionnement des doses assurée
par la production industrielle et le
déploiement d'un dispositif logistique
là encore les mesures seront prises les
deux premiers vaccins susceptibles
d'être autorisées seront en partie
fabriqué en france
ce sera une nouvelle garantie
d'approvisionnement et une
reconnaissance de notre filière dans le
dispositif européen les entreprises
delpharm et récits forme investissent
déjà sur leur site de production en
eure-et-loir et indre et loire pour
répondre à la demande tout comme le
groupe sanofi qui s'est engagée à
produire ce vaccin sur notre territoire
oui nous pouvons être fiers de notre
filière française de produits de santé
et de ses milliers de salariés qui n'ont
pas failli au coeur de la crise et qui
démontre aujourd'hui encore leurs
compétences enfin nous croyons à la
performance de notre chaîne logistique
qui a démontré sa totale réactivité au
pic de la crise le défi est de taille
il s'agira de stocker d'acheminer les
vaccins dans des milliers de structures
de vaccination dans des conditions de
conservation reprise des investissements
déjà été réalisés pour prendre en compte
ces exigences
mais seule une cohésion de l'ensemble de
la chaîne des acteurs de terrain et des
collectivités territoriales permettra la
réussite complète de cette campagne
chers collègues cette mobilisation
internationale pour trouver un vaccin et
sauver des vies nous rappelle combien
investir dans les technologies d'avenir
est indispensable nous mesurons à quel
point cette majorité a fait les bons
choix depuis le début de cette
législature en soutenant massivement
l'industrie et l'innovation en soutenant
l'investissement dans notre appareil
productif par une baisse de la fiscalité
par la modernisation de nos usines par
la simplification d'implantation de
nouveaux sites en soutenant la r&d et
notre système de recherche avec la
nouvelle loi de programmation le
développement de notre tissu industriel
l'attractivité scientifiques et
économiques du territoire pour lesquels
nous devons depuis 2010 est ce ne sont
pas uniquement des meilleurs chiffres
dans les classements internationaux
mais les capacités de résilience
indispensables au pays nous avons obtenu
de bons résultats dans cette crise
qu'un mouvement de réindustrialisation
et de création de centres de recherche
de pointe
nous devons encore l'amplifier pour
renforcer notre souveraineté
industrielle et particulièrement dans la
santé c'est le sens du plan de relance
adopté par la loi de finances et des 600
millions d'euros consacrés à la
relocalisation d'industries stratégiques
de nombreux projets sont déjà soutenu
par la filière des produits de santé
je pense à l'entreprise sequans pour la
production de principes actifs
c'est aussi le sens du quatrième
programme d'investissements d'avenir de
20 milliards d'euros qui permettra de
financer massivement l'innovation dans
nos filières stratégiques
mais au-delà de cette politique
industrielle d'innovation nous devons
protéger et encourager l'esprit français
de conquête technologique cet esprit de
louis pasteur de pierre et marie curie
qui semble oubliée par beaucoup dans
notre pays cet esprit d'emmanuel
charpentier nouvelle prix nobel de
chimie à qui je rends hommage à cette
tribune k recherche collègues les
antilles backs les complotistes les
professionnels du soupçon
les populistes congelé dans leur
idéologie et leur ego n'ont jamais rien
guérit jamais rien découvert et ne
seront jamais l'avenir de la france je
vous remercie
merci madame le bec
la parole est à madame marine brunier
pour les républicains et pour cinq
minutes
mais ce sera censé merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
la question que se posent tous les
français aujourd'hui est très simple
allons-nous vivre une année 2020
identique à celle de 2021
allons nous enfin sortir de cette
pandémie les désillusions ont été
nombreuses depuis mars dernier
le triptyque tester tracé isolé si
prometteur s'est révélé à être un outil
peut utiliser et surtout trop
tardivement
votre gouvernement n'a cessé d'être en
situation de réaction plutôt que
d'anticipation mais si nous souhaitons
que les gestes barrière ne soit qu'un
lointain souvenir dans quelques mois
nous devons non seulement prendre en
considération la saturation
psychologique qui touche les français
mais surtout leur scepticisme face à
l'arrivée d'un vaccin contre la croatie
19 nous le savons les français craignent
ce vaccin 59% d'entre eux affirment
qu'ils n'ont pas l'intention de se faire
vacciner si nos concitoyens sont aussi
méfiant c'est avant tout dû à un manque
évident de pédagogie et de transparence
nous devons apporter la lumière sur les
conditions de création de ce vaccin et
sa fiabilité afin de retrouver la
confiance de la population
la médecine n'est pas une science exacte
mais les experts semblent s'accorder sur
le fait que l'efficacité de ce vaccin
serait satisfaisante pour autant c'est
sur la tolérance que demeure encore
certaines inquiétudes dont il faut aussi
parler
nous devons apporter l'ensemble des
informations pour que chacun puisse
décider en son âme et conscience de se
faire vacciner
il semblerait que ces effets secondaires
soit plus fréquents chez les sujets
jeunes et en bonne santé
de plus il convient de rappeler que les
vaccins développés permettent certes
d'éviter de déclencher des formes graves
mais non de limiter la transmission du
virus au regard de l'analyse bénéfice
risque
il semblerait que cette campagne de
vaccination doivent se concentrer en
priorité sur les personnes âgées celles
atteintes de comment revisiter et le
personnel soignant
à ce titre je suis très surprise de
constater que les personnes âgées
isolées à domi
ils ne sont pas selon vous au rang des
prioritaires de la première phase je
tiens également rappeler ici
l'importance soutenu par notre groupe
l'est républicain de laisser le choix à
chacun de se faire vacciner ou non
sans confiance il ne peut y avoir de
campagne de grande ampleur la pédagogie
devra être le maître mot de notre
stratégie de vaccination
nous avons également des inquiétudes
concernant la plateforme déjà existantes
signalement santé qui permet
d'enregistrer les effets indésirables
des vaccins de la vie des soignants des
pharmaciens des passions cet outil n'est
pas suffisamment pratique pour être
utile à l'analyse des impacts du vaccin
nous avons également une chance inouïe
de pouvoir observer ce qui va se
dérouler dans nos pays voisins
oui l'union européenne fait un choix
collectif de prudence et de précaution
et nous ne pouvons à blâmer pour cela
profitons donc de ce temps pour étudier
les différentes campagnes de vaccination
déjà lancé en russie en grande bretagne
aux états unis
le défi logistique demanda vaccination
ainsi que la réaction des populations
différents vaccins en situation réelle
seront particulièrement utiles à la mise
en place de notre propre stratégie
à ce triste à ce titre vous devez vous
appuyez sur les collectivités
territoriales pour réussir cette
campagne de vaccination nous avons
peut-être face à nous l'opportunité
d'enrayer une crise sanitaire inédite
ne faites pas l'erreur de laisser sur le
bord du chemin ces collectivités
elles connaissent bien mieux que les ars
leurs populations et dispose des
infrastructures et moyens matériels pour
mener à bien ce déploiement sur le
territoire les élus locaux et les
professionnels de santé sont un relais
qui dispose d'un fort capital de
confiance auprès de nos concitoyens ils
seront prendre toutes leurs
responsabilités
souhaitons donc qu'après une mauvaise
gestion du stock des masques un retard
du déploiement des tests mais aussi les
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
vaccins contre la grippe
nous ne subissions pas la même en
préparation nous devons permettre à tous
ceux de nos concitoyens qui le
souhaitent de pouvoir se faire vacciner
dans les plus brefs délais nous avons
été élus vous avez été élu pour
gouverner
gouverner c'est prévoir mais c'est aussi
avant tout âge et en responsabilité la
société que nous connaissons est devenu
procédure ya c'est vrai la
responsabilité pénale et politiques de
chacun d'entre nous peut être mise en
jeu devant un tribunal comme devant nos
électeurs mais c'est justement ce sens
des responsabilités qui doit nous
conduire à agir et non à nous cacher
derrière un sondage ou un commentaire
la situation sanitaire social et
économique est inédite et nécessite de
votre part comme de la nôtre
un engagement plein et entier pour
l'avenir des français je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur jean françois illy out pour la
république en mars et pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues se
préoccuper de la vie et de la santé des
autres est une tâche ardue parfois
périlleuse mais toujours exaltante la
définition et la mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie vaccinale contre lacko vide
constitue cette ambition au bénéfice de
nos concitoyens
les vaccinations constitue un progrès
immense pour l'humanité en ce qu'elles
ont permis d'éradiquer de multiples
maladie infectieuse mortelle le
développement à marche forcée ces
derniers mois de plusieurs vaccins
contre lacko vide utilisant des
technologies variées est une très bonne
nouvelle et une prouesse scientifique
comme il en a rarement été réalisés il
faut saluer l'effort et les lits des
chercheurs du monde entier mais
également l'investissement financier
sans précédent des gouvernements et
notamment en europe qui ont permis
d'obtenir des vaccins efficaces ont un
temps record cependant le virus ne
disparaîtra pas d'un claquement de
doigts et son éradication ne se décrète
pas même après l'arrivée des vaccins
le succès des campagnes de vaccination
passera entre autres par la mise à
disposition et la délivrance des doses
vaccinales en nombre suffisant c'est
insisté aussi sur la place centrale
de la logistique garante d'efficacité
une logistique capable de relayer
pendant de relever des défis immenses
par exemple acheminer lors de la
première phase les doses vaccinales sans
rompre la chaîne du froid à quelque dix
mille établissements collectifs recevant
les personnes âgées sur notre territoire
et cela à deux reprises puisqu'il s'agit
de réaliser deux injections à trois
semaines d'intervalle les vaccins
devront être administré après
consentement éclairé par les médecins
traitants en collaboration bien sûr avec
les personnels soignants qui sont tous
au plus près de leur passion cette
vaccination de proximité sera un gage de
succès bien sûr pour les aspects
thérapeutiques mais également et surtout
peut-être parce que les médecins
traitants ont la confiance de nos
concitoyens
notre mission représentation nationale
est primordial
elle est définie à l'article 24 de la
constitution qui dispose que le
parlement contrôler l'action du
gouvernement et évalue les politiques
publiques
l'office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
l'opex participent à cette mission
ainsi l'office dont je suis un des
rapporteurs a été saisi par le président
de l'assemblée nationale et par notre
commission des affaires sociales après
de nombreuses auditions des principaux
acteurs de la politique vaccinale
décidée par le gouvernement après des
recommandations de la haute autorité de
santé
nous avons produit hier un premier
rapport qui vise à éclairer la
représentation nationale
ce rapport évalue la stratégie vaccinale
pour faire face à l'épidémie de kobe de
19 en abordant quatre axes le premier
concerne les connaissances et
incertitude scientifique sur le virus
sur la maladie sur la réponse
immunitaire et la réponse vaccinale
le deuxième axe détaille la stratégie de
vaccination progressive et les moyens
logistiques met en oeuvre le troisième
la dimension économique industrielle et
financière et enfin le quatrième axe
aborde le problème de la défiance et le
défi de la vaccination
la stratégie vaccinale volontairement
progressive adoptée par le gouvernement
et à laquelle j'adhère pleinement
consiste à vacciner dans un premier
temps nos concitoyens les plus âgés les
plus fragiles donc à risque de
développer des formes graves de co vide
elle est basée sur les publications de
données scientifiques et correspond à
une balance bénéfice risque favorable à
la population concernée par cette
première phase de vaccination
permettez moi chers collègues d'insister
maintenant sur l'acceptabilité de cette
vaccination qui concerne les adultes et
j'insiste qui concerne les adultes parce
que des questionnements et les doutes
sur cette maladie et les vaccins qui
seront utilisés sont légitimes
l'acceptabilité de la vaccination
passera par la transparence totale et la
précision des informations qui seront
communiqués à nos concitoyens à une
femme à cologie pharmacovigilance pardon
permanente un appel constant à leurs
responsabilités civiques de se protéger
individuellement pour le bien-être et la
santé de tous
enfin la gratuité le caractère non
obligatoire de cette vaccination qui
sera je le répète et je le souhaite
une vaccination de proximité positionne
en première ligne les médecins traitants
véritable vecteur de confiance auprès de
nos concitoyens pour terminer cher que
des nous devons continuer notre mission
de contrôle et d'évaluation avec
vigilance
précision et impartialité tout au long
du développement de la stratégie
vaccinale jusqu'à la disparition du
virus et ce au service de nos
concitoyens je vous remercie
merci chercher
la parole de madame emmanuelle antoine
pour le groupe l'est républicain et pour
cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
j'aimerais à mon tour attiré je l'espère
votre attention sur les enjeux que
recouvrent les modalités de déploiement
de la vaccination dans le cadre de la
lutte contre la copie de 19 la première
question qui se pose c'est celle des
délais d'approvisionnement
le gouvernement projette de vacciner un
million de personnes avaient indiqué fin
décembre prochain en janvier dans les
ehpad puis 14 millions de personnes
vulnérables à partir de février
or nous sommes confrontés au même
problème que pour l'approvisionnement en
masque en test que nous avons connu lors
du premier confinement un nombre limité
de producteur doit fournir le monde
entier la concurrence entre les pays
pour un bien aussi vital est de nature à
limiter le nombre de doses que la france
pourra acquérir à court terme les mois
de janvier et de février ne représente
pas un horizon très lointain
en réalité c'est demain l'annnonce du
retard de développement du vaccin franco
britannique
développé par sanofi et gsk révèle les
risques importants de tension sur
l'approvisionnement en vaccins dans des
délais brefs
ce dernier fournisseur ne pourra en
effet proposer des doses qu'à partir de
la fin de l'année 2021 un autre point
que je souhaite aborder concerne le
déploiement au niveau local de la
stratégie de vaccination le gouvernement
d'y être at il ses promesses d'associer
les collectivités locales dans sa
gestion de la crise les acteurs locaux
sont prêts à mettre la campagne
vaccinale en oeuvre sur le terrain ce
n'est d'ailleurs qu'au niveau des
territoires avec notamment les
collectivités locales les professionnels
de santé de ville et aussi la mise en
place de centres de vaccination que
l'accès au vaccin pour être pourra être
garantie à l'ensemble des français
le gouvernement va-t-il donc enfin faire
confiance réellement à ses partenaires
déjà opérationnels partout dans le pays
dernier point et non des moindres que je
souhaite évoquer ici le suivi des
personnes vaccinées
la campagne de vaccination ne doit pas
se limiter aux injections du vaccin mais
être prolongée par un réel suivi des
personnes vaccinées par une surveillance
de cohorte ce sera un élément important
pour assurer la confiance de la
population à l'égard du vaccin
ce suivi sur un terme et l'on doit
permettre de vérifier l'efficacité du
vaccin et l'absence d'effets secondaires
il nous offrira les données essentielles
pour garantir la réussite de la
stratégie de lutte contre la copie de 19
en même temps que l'adhésion de la
population à la campagne de vaccination
le gouvernement doit ainsi prévoir des
modalités plus approfondie afin de
permettre l'accès un suivi médical suite
à une vaccination
comment dans ces courts circonstances le
gouvernement peut-il nous assurer qu'il
pourra proposer l'accès à la vaccination
aux quarts de nos concitoyens dès les
premiers mois de l'année 2021 il faudra
très probablement attendre la fin du
printemps 2021
voire même l'été pour bénéficier d'une
couverture vaccinale suffisantes pour
enrayer l'épidémie et cette couverture
vaccinale optimale sera d'autant plus
difficile à atteindre que la vaccination
suscite des réticences voire de la
défiance parmi nos concitoyens qu'il est
important de prendre aussi en
considération semblerait pourtant que la
vaccination contre la copie de 19
représente dans la stratégie du
gouvernement
le remède miracle qui permettra de lever
à court terme les restrictions dont
notre pays souffre depuis bien trop
longtemps
mais face à ton hypothèse il est
nécessaire de prévoir d'autres solutions
pour être en mesure de garder la
maîtrise de l'épidémie
il serait illusoire de se reposer sur
l'accès à la vaccination et les mesures
que vous avez embauché pour éviter une
troisième vague et un nouveau
reconfirmant catastrophique
il semble en effet que si le vaccin
protège la personne qui s'est fait
vacciner
pour autant il n'empêche pas forcément
la transmission en outre la durée de sa
protection est inconnu aussi une preuve
plus grande rigueur en matière de
dépistage 10 seulement et de traçage des
contaminations est nécessaire les
dispositif actuellement proposé par le
gouvernement dans ce domaine reste
encore trop largement insuffisant pour
protéger notre pays vous le voyez il
reste encore un certain nombre de points
à éclaircir si vous souhaitez en
transparence gagner la confiance de nos
concitoyens
il importe que de réelles réponses ils
soient apportées alors monsieur le
premier ministre vous nous avez indiqué
je vous cite que l'arrivée du vaccin
marquera un tournant dans la lutte
contre la copie de 19 soit mais pour
autant c'est bien votre stratégie
vaccinale qui permettra de prendre ce
tournant tant attendu par les français
dans la lutte contre la copie de 19
merci chers collègues la parole thomas
la police à québec pour le groupe la
république au marché pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues après une année durant
laquelle ensemble nous avons fait face à
l'épidémie de lakovic 19 et à ses
conséquences douloureuses nous
concitoyens ont besoin de nouveaux
motifs d'espoir pour la nouvelle année
la politique d'acier vaccinale prendra
progressivement sa place aux côtés de la
stratégie tester alerte et protégé
développer jusqu'à présent dans cette
période difficile les vaccins apporte de
l'espérance à toutes les personnes
vulnérables malades qui ont reporté
leurs soins à nos aînés qui souffrent de
l'isolément à nos concitoyens
entrepreneurs indépendants salariés dont
les secteurs d'activité sont les plus
durement touchés au plus précaire qui
lutte pour s'en sortir
aux plus jeunes qui ne demandent qu'à se
projeter dans un futur meilleur
empli des belles opportunités que la
jeunesse promet et que la nation leur
dois à nous toutes et tous en fin de
toutes générations confondues qui
ressentons le besoin simple élémentaire
de tourner la page de nous retrouver en
famille de pratiquer nos activités
sociales culturelles sportif sans avoir
la crainte d'être contaminés ou d'être
vecteur de contamination
oui les vaccins nous donne l'espérance
résultat d'une prouesse scientifique
exceptionnel il offre tout simplement la
vie la survie à ce que la maladie
pourrait emporter dans les prochains
mois nous ne pouvons pas évoquer
l'histoire contemporaine de l'humanité
sans parler de l' avancée scientifique
majeure qu'ont été les vaccins et nous
ne pouvons pas évoquer l'histoire de la
médecine sans nommer louis pasteur et sa
découverte du vaccin contre la rage
sans mentionner marcel mérieux et
l'institut mérieux qu'il a fondé à lyon
en 1897
parmi leurs héritiers sanofi pasteur
développe sur son site de marcy l'étoile
dans l'agglomération lyonnaise un vaccin
qui sera produit en francs moss parmi
eux également l'institut pasteur
poursuit ses recherches et ses essais
cliniques
la présence dans notre pays de ses
acteurs de référence oms complémentarité
de la production des tests
réalisée par biomérieux sont des
marqueurs importants de notre
souveraineté et de notre indépendance en
matière de santé pouvoir nous appuyer
sur ses savoir-faire français dans la
recherche et dans la production médicale
garantit la sécurité qu attendent
légitimement nos concitoyens et facilite
grandement la chaîne logistique de la
stratégie mise en place
mais avant que ces perspectives ne
devienne une réalité concrète
nous devons avancer étape par étape avec
prudence il nous faudra évaluer
l'efficacité et les effets de chacun des
vaccins seule la rigueur et la
transparence nous permettront de lever
les doutes les craintes et de susciter
la confiance indispensable à l'adhésion
de nos concitoyens dans cette attente il
nous faudra encore respecté les gestes
barrière nous faire tester nous isoler
pour protéger les nôtres pour protéger
notre santé pour protéger les soignants
qui prennent des risques pour nous
soigner infirmières cadres de santé
avant de devenir député
je sais à quel point ces derniers mois
ont été difficiles pour les soignants à
travers ces mots je veux à nouveau
exprimé aux médecins aux professionnels
paramédicaux notre profonde
reconnaissance leur dire que derrière
leurs masques nous voyons leurs visages
fatigués qui exprime la lassitude
l'inquiétude est aussi parfois la
tristesse pour que la politique
vaccinale souhaite une pleine réussite
vous pourrez monsieur le premier
ministre vous appuyez sur l'expertisé
des médecins
vous pourrez également compter sur les
compétences les savoir-faire des
aides-soignants des infirmiers des
cadres de santé de toutes les
professions paramédicales les associés
les impliquer pleinement dans cette
stratégie vaccinale par exemple en
laissant la possibilité aux infirmiers
de vacciner serait une véritable marque
de reconnaissance
aussi j'espère c'est un appel que je
formule qu'un maximum d'entre eux
choisiront de se faire vacciner pour
leur santé et celle de leurs proches et
celle de leurs patients enfin chers
collègues j'aimerais terminer mes propos
par un appel humaniste les 9 et 10
octobre 2019 sous l'impulsion du
président de la république la france à
lyon
qui est la conférence du fonds mondial
de lutte contre le sida la tuberculose
et le paludisme dans la continuité de
cet engagement ford emmanuel macron
j'appelle à ce que la france oeuvrent
pour que toutes les avancées médicales
contre le cornard virus soit diffusée
largement ayant particulier des
populations les plus pauvres engager
notre nation dans cette voie honorât les
valeurs fondatrices de la république
valeurs pour lesquelles la france est
reconnue attendu je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole thomas
da vang gendt et pour la république en
marché pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues un bien public mondial
tels étaient les mots du président de la
république dès le 4 juin dernier lors du
dernier sommet mondial sur la
vaccination lorsqu'il évoquait le vaccin
dont nous parlons aujourd'hui un bien
public mondial qui ne serait être ni un
outil d'influencé ni l'objet de
tractations diplomatiques ni une source
d'enrichissement
un bien public mondial partout et pour
tous parce que la menace à laquelle nous
faisons face aujourd'hui ne se préoccupe
ni de frontières ni de nationalité ni de
pib un bien public donc pour la france
pour l'europe et pour le monde a bien
public pour la france d'abord en
cohérence avec nos valeurs républicaines
fondamentales de liberté celle de
choisir d'être ou de ne pas être
vaccinés d'égalité car tout le monde y
aura accès gratuitement dans nos villes
dans nos montagnes dans nos campagnes
dans nos silos prix d'un défi logistique
inégalée que nous relèverons assurément
de fraternité enfin car il sera d'abord
accessible aux plus fragiles et aux plus
exposés sans considération d'origine ou
de statut social et parce que cet
ensemble tous ensemble que nous
réussirons à atteindre cette épidémie va
bien public pour la france un bien
public pour l'europe qui a su anticiper
et négocier anticiper car dès le 16 juin
la commission européenne a présenté une
stratégie très ambitieuse ambitieuse en
termes de financement de la recherche en
posant sur la table 2,15 milliards
d'euros ambitieuse aussi en termes
d'objectifs car elle projetait que le
vaccin fut prêt fin 2021
nous avons largement devancé ce
calendrier négocié ensuite négocier des
contrats d'achat au nom de tous les
états membres avec six laboratoires pour
près de 1 3 milliard de doses afin de
garantir un accès équitable à un prix
abordable 9 euros la dose partout et
pour tous ainsi en cohérence avec la
devise européenne
unis dans la diversité nous voyons là se
construire une véritable europe de la
santé qui n'en doutons pas survivre à
l'épidémie un bien public pour la france
pour l'europe mais un bien public
mondial enfin pour la santé dans le
monde
la france y est toujours engagé car
aujourd'hui comme hier la france est
fidèle à ses engagements en faveur d'un
multilatéralisme fort autour de la santé
mondiale
rappelons-nous dans les années 2000 le
fonds mondial de lutte contre le sida la
tuberculose et le paludisme ou bien à
l'alliance gavi pour la vaccination et
puis en 2006 unis tijd pour des
médicaments à prix abordable c'est aussi
le président de la république qui
poursuit et qui porte cette vision
solidaire global coopérative de la santé
lorsqu en 2019 il augmente de 20%
notre contribution au fonds mondial dans
le même esprit de solidarité
la france va augmenter de 25% sa
contribution à l'alliance mondiale gavi
la portant à 500 millions d'euros afin
que le droit fondamental de chacun à la
santé quel que soit le pays où il vit
devienne réalité
et puis le 16 avril dernier pour
répondre à cette crise sanitaire inédite
également dans les pays les plus
vulnérables
la france a lancé l'initiative colis 19
santé en commun qui vise à accélérer
dans ces pays le développement et
l'accès aux traitements au diagnostic et
au vaccin
les chers collègues le vaccin ne doit
être ni un enjeu économique ni un enjeu
géostratégique
le vaccin est avant tout un enjeu de
santé publique mondial et c'est le
devoir et l'honneur de la france que de
soutenir et défendre cette position
universaliste
c'est ce qui a guidé les choix de notre
majorité c'est ce qui devra tous nous
anime et pour les mois et années à venir
écoutons victor hugo même la nuit la
plus sombre prendra fin et le soleil se
lèvera le vaccin mes chers collègues et
cette lumière qui va redonner espoir à
l'humanité
alors soyons tous fiers que notre pays
porte cette lumière
soyons tous fiers que le président de la
république porte ces valeurs
universalistes
et soyons tous dire que tout au long de
cette interminable crise sanitaire
nous n'aurons jamais perdu de vue notre
mission celle de protéger toutes les
femmes toutes les sommes tous les
enfants et de briser les inégalités les
inégalités de santé
vive le vaccin partout et pour tous
merci chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur cédric villani
président de l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques pour cinq minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
en mars dernier les meilleurs experts
prévenait qu'il ne fallait pas compter
sur un vaccin qu'ovide avant 18 mois et
peut-être de longues années seulement
neuf mois plus tard le vaccin devenu
réalité
cela grâce à une mobilisation sans
précédent de la recherche internationale
et des avancées scientifiques
impressionnante pour s'adapter à cette
accélération l'opex à travailler dans
les délais inédit
c'est le 20 novembre que le président
ferradj a saisi du sujet de la stratégie
vaccinale suivi par la commission des
affaires sociales en moins de quatre
semaines le rapport a été préparé et
distribué pour que ces recommandations
puissent nourrir vos débats quatre
rapporteurs ont été désignés dans un
esprit trans partisan deux d'entre eux
sont exprimées aujourd'hui nos collègues
gérard le seul groupe socialiste et jean
françois illy ou de la république en
marche
les deux autres s'exprimeront demain
sont les sénatrices florence lassarade
groupe est républicain et sonia de la
provôté union centriste
ce panel a bousculé les emplois du temps
pour mener un grand nombre d'auditions
dont certaines retransmise en public
dans un format interactif
au-delà de l'aspect strictement
scientifique et technologique
la mission a abordé trois volets qui en
l'occurrence ne peuvent en être
dissociée la mise en oeuvre pratique de
la vaccination
les enjeux économiques industriels
nationaux et internationaux et enfin le
volet capital de la confiance
si la mission a globalement approuvé par
consensus la stratégie vaccinale du
gouvernement elle a aussi mis en valeur
plusieurs sujets de vigilance et
apporter de nombreuses recommandations
cette stratégie lutte contre une maladie
singulière parfois très graves et qui a
endeuillé cet hémicycle même maladie
encore mystérieuses à bien des égards
notamment en matière d'immunité maladie
face à laquelle nous sommes très inégaux
particulièrement selon la
le taux de mortalité et 800 fois plus
élevé pour les plus de 80 ans que pour
les moins de 25 ans face à cela plus de
50 vaccins en cours d'essai clinique
dans le monde dont certains
remarquablement innovants ainsi les
vaccins adénovirus développer en russie
grande-bretagne etats-unis où les
vaccins arn développée aux états-unis en
allemagne
ces technologies n'en sont pas à leur
coup d'essai mais c'est la première fois
qu'elles seront mises en oeuvre à si
grande échelle
le premier vaccin disponible développé
par pfizer avec la start up allemande
biotech deviendra peut-être l'emblème
d'une nouvelle ère dans la vaccination
il n'est pas certain que ce vaccin
empêche la transmission mais il a
démontré sa grande efficacité pour
empêcher les formes graves
même chez les personnes âgées tout cela
ainsi que la disponibilité progressive
des doses plaide pour une stratégie
progressive de vaccination avec priorité
aux personnes pour lesquelles la balance
bénéfices risques est incontestablement
favorable
cela doit aller de pair avec une
pharmacovigilance très rigoureuse la
mise en oeuvre un pic tout un ensemble
complexe d'institutions le comité vaccin
à prospecter la haute autorité de santé
définit la stratégie la rsm confirmera
l'autorisation éminent de l'agencé
européen
les comités qu'ovide passe la main au
comité valls vaccin multi-compétences
monté par la figure très respectée du
chercheur alain fischer la logistique
partagé entre santé publique france les
services ministériels la taskforce
interministériel est extraordinairement
complexe du fait de la fragilité du
vaccin du défi de la traçabilité de la
deuxième injection du recueil du
consentement
tous les organismes impliqués ont joué
leur rôle avec rigueur à ce jour dans la
suite il faudra veiller à la lisibilité
clarté de leurs rôles respectifs pour
éviter que cette complexité uns
deviennent cacophonie et bien sûr
réaffirmer le rôle de contrôle du
parlement pour la stratégie elle même il
a large consensus pour une vaccination
non obligatoire
le texte recommande de permettre une
large et rapide vaccination des
professionnels de santé volontaires pour
la protection et pour la confiance de
bien définir le protocole de recueil du
consentement en ehpad d'employés très
largement les professionnels de santé de
ville dès la deuxième phase de sécuriser
leur intervention via l'oniam d'
impliquer fortement les élus locaux pour
la date de démarrage le plus tôt est le
mieux mais il est non moins capitale de
prendre le temps de vérifier que tout
est en place pour une action rigoureuse
et simultanés en chaque point un
territoire français solidairement s'il
faut pour cela à reculer de quelques
petits jours la date de début de la
vaccination
cela ne remettra en rien la stratégie en
cause en matière de négociations
économiques pour la première fois les
pays européens ont fait le choix
remarqua de négociation collective sur
l'analyse de l'opex stratégie se compare
très favorablement la stratégie
britannique notre côté les états unis
ont très bien tirer parti de leurs
grandes agences sanitaires labarda pour
investir massivement très tôt et sur
toute la chaîne cet exemple peut
inspirer l'europe de même qu'un fonds
d'investissement d'urgence européen
alimenté par les états membres et la
transparence à échéance sur les contrats
la souveraineté sanitaires européennes
servir à nouveau comme un enjeu majeur
dernier défi et non le moindre sou la
confiance dans la vaccination
la forte défiance française
multifactorielle ne peut se réduire à
des thèses complotistes et ne pourra
surmonter que par la transparence le
débat ouvert la communication des faits
et des liens d'intérêts la mobilisation
des acteurs
le secours des cendres humaines et
sociales il faudra l'information
complète des professionnels de santé et
des élus locaux
mes chers collègues si ce vaccin n'est
peut-être pas la panacée thérapeutique
c'est en tout cas un progrès capital qui
portera ses fruits dans la
juré il faudra savourer cette innovation
et dans les mois à venir et c'est une
extrême prudence au quotidien et avoir
conscience des enjeux gigantesque qui
sont derrière défis sanitaires progrès
inouïe des biotechnologies affirmation
progressif de l'europe
et finalement la réaffirmation que les
plus grandes difficultés à venir sont
moins liées à la complexité du monde
environnement qu'à notre propre
complexité d'êtres humains je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre vous voulez monsieur bré
ministre venez ici
[Applaudissements]
je n'en doutais pas ce député monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
nous voici donc au terme de ce débat
dont je voudrais avec vous toutes et
vous tous me réjouir à la fois de la
sérénité et de la très grande qualité
la très grande qualité je voudrais sur
tous les bancs de cette assemblée salué
l'esprit de responsabilité je mesure
bien que le parlement dans son ensemble
a parfaitement conscience du défi
collectif qui s'offre à nous et que au
delà de nos différences elles sont
parfaitement légitimes
j'ai bien senti quelques piques elle
m'aurait manqué si elle n'avait pas été
là mais j'ai quand même compris qu'avec
vous en réalité le peuple français est
évidemment un tiens il n'a jamais été un
grand fanatique de la vaccination nous
le savons et vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
bien avant la survenance de la crise
dako vide mais nous mesurons nous
mesurerons kid est à notre portée qu'en
suscitant chez lui une forme de
confiance qui l'a sans doute sinon
perdue en tous cas qui s'est altérée il
peut comme j'en suis sûre il comprend le
fondement des mesures difficiles que
nous prenons au fond de lui-même dans
son bon sens
regardons aussi ce qui se passe dans
tous les pays qui nous entourent
il peut finalement comprendre qu'il est
dans son intérêt de se faire vacciner
non seulement dans l'intérêt individuel
personnel mais comme cela a été dit par
plusieurs d'entre vous parce que c'est
aussi
une mesure de solidarité et d'intérêt
pour les autres un peu les mêmes
sentiments finalement qui devrait nous
habite et lorsque nous respectons les
gestes barrière lorsque pour les fêtes
de fin d'année nous ferons l'effort de
ne pas nous retrouver extrêmement
nombreux dans des lieux secrets pour
sûrement passer un bon moment mais
ensuite contribué à la propagation du
virus
une nouvelle fois il s'agira d'un acte
de responsabilité individuelle et
collective on voudrait peut-être pas sur
tous les bancs que l'état soit une
nouvelle fois responsable de tout j'ai
souvent eu l'occasion de dire ici qu'il
doit exercer les responsabilités
je crois en l'état faisait toujours dit
dès ma déclaration de politique générale
j'y crois d'autant plus quand on est en
crise si l'état a vraiment rôle c'est
bien dans les moments historiques ou la
nation est affaibli et ne l'est-elle pas
et comment depuis plusieurs mois donc
merci mesdames et messieurs les députés
pour cet esprit de responsabilité et je
ne doute pas qu'il perdurera je ne doute
pas davantage que vous continuerez à
exercer le rôle qui est le vote de
contrôle de l'action gouvernementale
d'exigence à l'endroit de ceux qui sont
en responsabilité mais j'aimais
aujourd'hui le veut près de six mois
après ma prise de fonction
que nous le fassions dans un esprit de
consensus minimum
mesdames et messieurs députés qui voyez
bien l'image que nous renvoyons à nos
concitoyens est aussi nécessaire pour
réussir ce formidable défi de la
vaccination collective
j'apprécie aussi que vous disiez parce
que c'est un élément de fierté
collective finalement que cette crise
survenue en ce début de xxième siècle où
on se croyait peut-être un vin
cible dans le monde occidental où la
médecine et la science toute puissante
se sont trouvés un peu aculé bien voilà
si je puis me permettre que la science
se rebiffe
voilà vous l'avez dit qu'elle a au point
d'ailleurs de susciter le doute mis les
bouchées doubles pour sortir ce ou
plutôt ses vaccins avait des techniques
innovantes qui de fait pose question
mais c'est bien le rôle de la science et
les pouvoirs publics en france comme
ailleurs ont beaucoup contribué à cette
accélération
c'est donc un moment d'espoir devant
lequel nous nous trouvons c'est un
rendez-vous exigeant pour nous car il ne
faut pas rater ce virage
et comme je voulais expliquer comme
olivier véran vous l'a dit avec
davantage encore de précision que moi
comme nous continuerons à le faire parce
que cette stratégie elle va s'affiner
elle va s'adapter vous avez bien compris
que tous les vaccins ne sont pas les
mêmes
et qu'en conséquence la logistique
nécessaire pour arriver à leur
distribution sera forcément différente
évolutive mais nous le ferons avec les
principes que je vous ai rappelé dans
mon propos introductif et que je n'ai
pas vu invalidées par vos interventions
successives nous le ferons dans la
transparence
je les dis nous allons encore accroître
les efforts de transparence que je
considère que nous avons toujours fait
mais il faut savoir écouter nous serons
encore davantage transparent dans cette
phase de gestion de l'épidémie
nous progressons nous devons
collectivement toujours toujours
progresser je n'ai pas par exemple
olivier ferrand l'a fait mais cela a été
dit évoquer un élément de cette
crédibilisation de cette sécurité de
cette france
qu'est ce qu'on appelle la
pharmacovigilance vous avez raison il
faudra mettre
des suivis et nous allons nous les avons
prévu de le faire des suivis des
personnes vaccinées avec des dispositifs
de pharmacovigilance qui seront
évidemment supérieur encore renforcée
par rapport à ce qui existe dans le
cadre des vaccinations habituelles
bien entendu je les dis mais je le
répète à ce micro les associations
d'usagers
les professionnels de santé les élus
locaux dans les territoires notamment
dans les phases vaccinale où celle ci va
se diffuser le plus possible partout
dans tous les villages
tous ces acteurs qui maillent notre
territoire
sous l'impulsion et la direction du
ministère de la santé de l'état car nous
sommes dans une politique sanitaire
c'est à dire une politique de l'état
tous ces acteurs seront effectivement
mis à contribution et nous avons vous
l'avez dit aussi le défi logistique du
dernier kilomètre qui est évidemment au
centre de notre occupation qui vous le
savez n'est pas le plus simple
n'a jamais été le plus simple des
rapaces que vous n'y êtes pas préparé on
fait tout pour s'y préparer b je vais
vous dire moi qui ai quand même quelques
années d'expérience jamais nous avons
nous n'avons eu à gérer une telle
massification des processus
on ne peut pas dire que nous ayons une
expérience forte de remercier d'une
certaine manière sur laquelle nous
appuyer pour faire face à ce à ce type
de défi et pourtant et pourtant nous
nous y préparons nous nous y préparons
du mieux possible vous avez également me
semble-t-il adhérer au fait c'est une
évidence que cette stratégie du
déploiement des vaccins elle sera
progressive tout au long du premier
semestre ne serait ce que parce que la
politique d'approvisionnement qui est la
nôtre qui est en réalité européenne ne
peut être que progressive j'en profite
pour vous répondre à une question nous
attendons d'ici la fin de ce mois d'ici
la fin de ce mois nous serons livrés
très précisément d'ici le 30 décembre
1 millions 160 me de doses un million
cent soixante mille doses seront sur le
territoire national du premier vaccin
donc d'ici la fin de l'année avec je
voulais 10 des premières vaccinations on
fera tout notre possible de façon
harmonisée avec les pays européens pour
commencer la dernière semaine de noël
nous devrions recevoir 600 117,8 doses
supplémentaires autour du 5 6 janvier et
1 million 600 mille doses en février je
vous donnerai le ministère nous vous
donnerons évidemment tous les
calendriers suivante ils dépendent
évidemment des conditions de fabrication
dans les laboratoires auprès desquels
nous nous fournissons plus exactement
auprès desquels l'europe se fournit je
voudrais aussi vous dire que nous le
faisons tout cela dans l'humilité c'est
un terme qui revenu dans plusieurs de
vos interventions
et croyez bien que cette même humilité
être toujours partagé par les
gouvernants lorsqu'on doit prendre des
décisions difficiles nous devons prendre
des décisions pour faire face à
l'épidémie
nous mesurerons autant que vous les
difficultés qu'elle occasionne pour nos
concitoyens
autant que vous je vous rassure pas
moins sûrement pas plus mais nous devons
prendre nos responsabilités parce
qu'après je sais ce qui se passerait si
nous ne les prenions pas donc la
sécurité la santé a toujours été au
coeur de nos préoccupations
toujours si vous cherchez une cohérence
à l'action du gouvernement de la
république française c'est la protection
de la santé de nos concitoyens
d'abord d'abord
cela a des conséquences dommageables sur
certains secteurs
et oui on est obligé quand l'épidémie
flom n'y a pas que nous d'ailleurs vous
le voyez de prendre des mesures valeur
si j'écoutais semaine après semaine nous
n'aurions jamais confie n'ai jamais rien
faire mais j'ai toujours été une fois
c'est et les discothèques
une fois ça a été les bars les
restaurants une fois ça a été des
commerces les établissements culturels
les pistes de ski fait il ya toujours
d'excellentes raisons que je comprends
pour ne pas faire mais toujours bon mais
si je les écoute toutes mises bout à
bout on ne prend plus de mesures pour
faire face à l'épidémie
et là vous me reprochez y est je vous le
dis avec beaucoup plus de raison qu'il y
aurait des taux d'incidence des taux
d'hospitalisation et des morts dans les
services de réanimation beaucoup
beaucoup plus nombreux ça mesdames et
messieurs les députés
vous devez en avoir la certitude
et donc oui la santé d'abord la santé
d'abord je reçus je remarque que des
dirigeants de très grand état du monde
n'ont pas fait ce choix
ils ont eu tort à tous égards y compris
politiquement je vous fait aussi
observer ce sera le dernier point de mon
intervention après vous avoir écouté que
finalement nous nous avons raison
d'avoir peur un certain nombre de
dispositions à caractère beaucoup plus
structurelle que les sujets de la
stratégie vaccinale qui sont évidemment
essentiel
qu'avez vous dit vous avez parlé de
souvent interne izarra c'est bien
dommage
il ya des vaccins qu'on le devrait
produire ici à l'industrie
pharmaceutique nationale qui devrait
être favorisée dois je vous rappeler
mesdames et messieurs députés que un des
axes essentiels du plan de relance
avec des crédits affectés à cet effet
vise à renationaliser en france à
relocaliser en france une partie de
notre industrie des produits de santé ou
autres et que déjà les appels à projets
nous y reviendrons le moment venu sur ce
parti-là du plan de relance produit
produit des résultats tout à fait
significatif y compris dans le champ des
produits de santé
la souveraineté selon nous elle est
aussi européenne et je me réjouis de ce
que vous vous soyez finalement la
plupart d'entre vous féliciter du
dispositif d'approvisionnement en
vaccins qu'à l'initiative de la france
l'europe et la task force qu'elle a
constituée a réussi à mettre en boîte
c'est une initiative française je
voudrais remercier ici publiquement les
ministres
agnès pannier une hache et clément bonne
tous les temps ils sont sur le front
parce que on ne le lui passé ils vont
mesdames et messieurs les députés ils
vont négocier avec les autorités
européennes ces contrats c'est l'honneur
de notre pays
c'est l'honneur de notre pays c'est
aussi notre conception de la
souveraineté la souveraineté nationale
et la souveraineté européenne elle ne
s'oppose pas elle ne s'oppose pas la
preuve n'est deuxièmement vous avez
parlé de la recherche et vous avez bien
raison vous avez bien raison de parler
de la recherche et bien que je sache
vous avez voté récemment une loi de
programmation de la recherche
je le dis je les trouvais sur la table
quand je suis arrivé dans ses fonctions
de premier ministre
elle a sûrement des défauts mais en
termes d'ampleur et de moyens financiers
dégagés
je suis absolument formel il y a fort
longtemps qu'une loi il faut remonter au
début des années 80 sur la recherche
n'avait pas dégagé pour la recherche et
notamment pour la recherche publique
autant de moyens et votre assemblée
votre majorité peuvent en être fiers
parce que c'est aussi
une des leçons de cette crise et enfin
beaucoup l'ont dit il ya notre système
de santé
notre système de soins qui a beaucoup
souffert qui a beaucoup souffert qui
fait face qui fait face oui qui fait
face remarquablement sais j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps à les visiter avant et
pendant cette deuxième vague nos
hôpitaux
bon je les aimais déjà beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup travaillé dans ce secteur bien
avant que d'être premier ministre
c'était absolument formidable c'est
absolument formidable et le non moins
formidable ministre de la santé qui
m'accompagnait peut en témoigner parce
que je peux vous dire que ils ont agit
et réagit avec une conscience
professionnelle un dévouement qui fait
l'honneur de notre pays est bien là
aussi là aussi vous avez vous avez
l'occasion de voter sur un ségur de la
santé qui monsieur le président est un
tournant on peut arriver n'a pas été
fait avant et c'est sûrement va se
disputer les responsables l'enfant tout
cas certains ont même parlé de
rattrapage mais c'est déjà un compliment
le mot rattrapage en tout cas vous
pouvez là aussi être fier que nous ayons
su collectivement tirer les leçons
structurelles de ce qui se passe c'est à
dire que notre devoir notre honneur
notre obligation
c'est à la fois de gérer cette crise au
quotidien avec le souci de protéger nos
concitoyens qui sont dans des situations
parfois extrêmement difficile d'adopter
des dispositifs d'accompagnement
financier mais aussi humain et
psychologique les plus ambitieux et en
même temps de continuer à préparer
l'avenir et me semble-t-il monsieur le
président en parler d'avenir
lorsqu'on conclu un débat sur la
vaccination pour faire face à cette
épidémie et nous l'espérons tous y
mettre un terme
cela s'imposer je vous remercie
merci monsieur le premier ministre c'est
premier ministre ce débat est clos
il était attendu il était nécessaire je
remercie l'ensemble des collègues qui
ont pris part prochaine séance demain 9
heures lecture définitive du projet de
loi de finances pour 2021 lecture
définitive du projet de loi relatif à la
restitution de biens culturels au bénin
et au sénégal lecture définitive du
projet de loi relatif au code de la
sécurité intérieure la séance est levée